so we got more leaks coming out of the
Supreme Court they're not nearly as
egregious as the first leak the first
leak we saw was for the first time in
history an initial draft had been
released to the public but this draft on
the repealing of or the the overturning
of Roe v Wade was from February so a lot
of people were thinking look maybe maybe
it will have changed by now it's
certainly going to be a different
argument because the justices have
weighed in we now have several
conservative clerks telling the
Washington Post that the justices who
have voted to overturn Roe v Ro and
Casey have not changed their minds
Clarence Thomas says they won't be
bullied and of course this is resulting
in
continued outrage and uh people on the
left losing their minds it's it's I got
to be honest it's very strange to me
because all this does is return the
issue to the states it's not a ban on on
abortion several States will ban
abortion but these are overwhelmingly
Republican states anyway and the urban
liberal women who are freaking out don't
live in these places I just
I understand some of them may and they
may be concerned about it but I just
think we're not getting a real argument
for the most part from the people
screaming no more dating and they're on
a sex strike where that's literally what
conservatives would prefer in the whole
issue so anyway the conflict is rising
we have a new Theory out of NPR that was
actually a conservative Justice that
leaked the initial draft in order to
force the conservative justices to
retain that position otherwise it would
appear that they were swayed by the
public so we'll talk about that we'll
talk about the riots and the violence
that have happened at these pro-life
centers and ngos we also have protesters
plan on going to more homes of Supreme
Court Justices which is is illegal but
you know I'll be it
you guys think anybody's gonna get
arrested I really doubt it and then we
have Elon Musk who said he might die in
mysterious circumstances and then of
course there's the food shortage and a
whole bunch of uh other stuff like that
so uh it should be interesting joining
us to talk about all of this is Daryl
Cooper
you want to introduce yourself there
yeah my name is Daryl Cooper as Tim said
I am the host of the martyrmade podcast
and the co-host of the unraveling with
Jocko willink live in San Diego and um
I make podcasts right on what kind of
what what do you normally talk about
like what's here so martyrmade is it's a
long form History Podcast episodes that
come out every several months they're
three four five sometimes seven hours
long I dig deep into historical topics
sometimes I'll pick one it'll be a
single episode like my most recent
episode was about Niche and Dostoevsky
and how their ideas and biographies kind
of have interplay but sometimes I'll do
seven episodes on the Jonestown cult or
six episodes on the israeli-palestinian
conflict oh wow yeah before the show
you're talking a little bit about
Jonestown so we probably have a lot to
talk about because I usually refer to a
lot of these people as cultists you know
so we'll talk about that and uh thanks
for hanging out man thanks for everybody
we got Seamus Sheamus of Freedom Tunes I
make cartoons on a channel called
Freedom Tunes if you'll guy if y'all
want to you know go check that out I
think you'll enjoy it we're gonna be
uploading a cartoon on Thursday and yeah
man this situation is uh is hilarious
the idea of like a sex strike because if
conservatives are going to hear they go
no please anything but that liberal
women like it's so ridiculous and also
it's really offensive to women to assume
that all of their political capital is
just having sex like to to imply that
you view that to be a woman's role in
society and what they're good for in the
way that they should affect political
changes really objectifying it's it's
like men will respond to this yeah and
all the conservatives are like we agree
with it yeah like stop they get married
yeah
I'm just double checking but Liz Estrada
is the Greek play that was about the
women refusing sex to the men so that
they would I think not go to war or
something like that and it was a comedy
you know it's just the the entire
concept of the Society of women not
having sex anymore is hilarious uh it's
ridiculous uh I don't you know it's also
blackmail but we'll see if it works I
guess I want to show you guys before we
get started Tim got this for me it's uh
it's a no a ten dollar note from the
bank of Columbus Georgia before the
Federal Reserve existed States used to
issue their own currency well it's
actually a national yeah this is a
national that's a issued by a bank yeah
yeah so I was at a collector's shop and
the guy said this is pre-federal reserve
money and I was like oh I got to get
that first I said the magic words
pre-federal Reserve yeah well hey good
to see you man I am also here in the
corner pushing buttons I just wanted to
weigh in on this conversation about a
possible sex strike and I think that
these ladies are using this as an excuse
to pretend that they're getting laid I
don't believe any of them are actually
getting any that's my two cents well as
an aside there's a meme from
conservatives where it's like the women
going on a sex strike and it's a bunch
of like frumpy purple-haired women yeah
it says the women not going on strike
and has a bunch of like busty Trump
supporting women so I mean look look
last time I brought this up The Young
Turks were very offended but then
confirmed what I said was true
conservatives tend to be more attractive
than liberals according to multiple
studies that's right that doesn't mean
every conservative doesn't mean every
liberal they're attractive Lefty women
they're attractive conservative women
but it's a tendency among both males and
females and uh The Young Turks are
really mad at me for saying it and then
while they made fun of me and called me
ugly they confirmed everything I said so
that's there you go all right everybody
before we get started head over to eat
right and feelwell.com and you can pick
up your keto Elevate at chmct oil powder
51 off today I have cut out the sugars I
have been enjoying my C8 MCT oil powder
in my coffee
and uh actually I've lost like 25 pounds
since last November no joke yeah I was I
was getting big and uh I didn't really
care and then one day I decided to care
and stopped eating garbage started
focusing on actually I was I was eating
this stuff for a while by the way but I
just wasn't really I just eating too
much sugar too much grains cut all that
stuff out white melted right off head
over to eat right and feelwell.com
you'll get a 60 day money back guarantee
keto Elevate provides your body only C8
the most ketogenic MCT that means it
provides support for energy levels
healthy appetite Management Mental
Clarity and focus athletic performance I
can attest to that for sure I've been
skating almost every day keto Elevate is
my favorite MCT powder on the market
today you'll get free shipping on every
order for every order today BioTrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you will get free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order again
eat right and feelwell.com thanks
BioTrust and I just want to mention one
thing as an aside too
every so often I'll have a cheat day
where everybody wants to go out to eat
and the food options are you know grainy
or sugary but I'm like it's no big deal
it's like you know I've been eating
really well all month and then I'll have
that one day where I'll eat something
sugary and I'll eat something with bread
knit and then I just feel like someone
smacked me in the face with a with a
plank of wood they call it cheating for
a reason because you're not supposed to
do it it like it actually just feels
miserable after doing it and I'm
experiencing it right now because we
went out to eat for Mother's Day and I
was like we got to get the best of the
best and and the fancy desserts and now
I'm just like what's wrong with me so
anyway I read an article one time that
said that that's actually scientifically
good for you and I don't know if it's
true but I was like I'm going with that
a cheat day yeah well I guess the idea
is that you you get you overload so you
get everything you might be missing so I
think I was actually uh low on iron Ian
oh I think I'm low in iron yeah iron
sorry I was like oh yeah because I
didn't eat a steak for a while so I was
like because I was eating eggs and bacon
we actually have cast iron pans they're
supposed to cook in your cast iron pan
to get more iron in your diet I've heard
really yeah well anyway head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support our work we have brought on a
couple new opinion writers and
journalists as I've recently got the
red-headed libertarian who's been
writing and Josie has been writing up
really amazing stuff you'll definitely
want to check this out because she wrote
something really interesting on property
rights of slavery and abortion it makes
an interesting point that
arguably people who believe in abortion
after the second trimester would
probably not have been abolitionists
which is interesting because we'll talk
a little bit about that in in the
arguments but if you become a member
you're helping to support our writers
our columnists and you will get access
to exclusive segments of this show
Monday through Thursday at 11 PM these
are the uncensored and not
family-friendly versions of the show
where people are like wow you guys kind
of go over the top on that but it's
really let's just call it candid
swearing you know brutal conversations
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends let's jump
into this first story we have from
mediaite Washington Post obtains new
leaks from Supreme Court revealing
conservative justices are holding the
line not just that Chief Justice John
Roberts appears to have lost control and
Clarence Thomas may now actually be in
in more control we don't know exactly we
don't know exactly there's only a couple
leaks the first leak was the initial
draft check this out mediaite says oddly
the article itself appears to include
another leak which is clearly reported
to have come from conservatives close to
the court who of course spoke on the
condition of anonymity the sources are
said to have told reporters about
private conversations between Roberts
and his fellow jurists as far back as
early December they say
the leaked draft opinion is dated in
February and is almost surely obsolete
now as justices have had time to offer
descents and revisions but as of last
week the majority of five justices to
strike Roe remains intact according to
three conservatives close to the court
who like others spoke on the condition
of anonymity to discuss a sensitive
matter so we don't know who these people
are clearly someone who knows what's
going on in the court presumably a clerk
they say a person close to the most
conservative members of the Court said
Roberts told his fellow jurists in
private conference in early December he
plans to uphold the state law and write
an opinion that left Rowan Casey in
place for now but the other
conservatives were more interested in an
opinion that overturned the Precedence
the person said the spokesman for the
court declined to comment and messages
extended to justices were unreturned
also according to the Washington Post
they said it seems that Clarence Thomas
was the one who who instructed Alito to
draft the majority opinion and Alito has
always been in favor of uh restrictions
on abortion and opposing Roe v Wade so
it looks like Roberts was trying to get
the conservatives to side with upholding
Roe v Wade and they basically said nope
nope absolutely not so thank goodness
well so is this is this bad let me let
me show you the the big point of the
story
the hill regurgitating an NPR story says
the leading theory on scotus leak is a
conservative Clerk and the argument is
with Justice John Roberts trying to get
these other conservative justices to
uphold Roe v Wade a conservative clerk
released the draft opinion to force them
to stick to it because if they changed
their opinion now it'll look like they
were swayed by public opinion what do
you guys think I mean if NPR said it I'm
gonna say probably not true
I think that and if you're leaking
supreme court documents that's probably
a federal offense yeah exactly I mean
regardless this is a serious
um this is a serious breach of Ethics I
don't care who did it or why we need to
find them and we need to punish them
yeah what do you think it seems like
part of a larger Trend uh toward just
undermining all of our institutions
right and all of the customs and ways of
doing things that have kind of been the
glue and sinews that have held things
together over all this time right the
United States is a country
we got all types of people here you know
from every continent on the planet every
religion every every race everything
people who believe that all different
types of ways of life are you know the
most appropriate way to live and you
hold that together
by by a thread and that thread is those
traditions and customs and those
institutions that we use to moderate our
conversations with one another
and if we lose those things we're going
to lose everything I saw this uh leftist
meme post where they said Republicans
are trying to burn the country down and
destroy all of its institutions and I
thought to myself that is absolutely
accurate 100 the institutions that have
been taken over the left the
conservatives are absolutely intent on
on on taking down like public education
the Department of Education colleges so
um if you think about it in terms of
what we value as as constitutional
constitutionalists
when I hear that the constitutionalist
part of me says that's ridiculous the
left has been gutting and destroying
everything they're the ones stripping
the Bill of Rights and blah blah but I
don't I don't want to just be you know
overtly biased I was like well what
institutions are they talking about I'm
like oh yeah the universities yeah
definitely cultural institutions oh you
bet they've been completely taken over
so I think conservatives would love to
see the universities falter well but
when we're talking about courts when
we're talking about the rule of law
that's that's absolutely not true it's
the left that's doing that in my opinion
again there's two different layers to
institutions right there's there's
Harvard University and then there's
education in the United States or
there's the Washington Post but then
there's journalism which is an
institution right and they certainly
want to burn the Washington Post and
Harvard you know Harvard down but I
think that
in their minds at least conservatives
want to do that so they can get back
well this is this is it's a really
interesting point
the left I think looks at the the brick
and mortar structure as the institution
and the right views the concept as the
institution a a just court is an
institution to the left the Supreme
Court is the institution the court
itself the building itself well I think
the left knows that they're going to be
able to intimidate people into doing
their bidding by going after the actual
physical location so you look at the
fact that they are genuinely trying to
intimidate Supreme Court Justices and I
think that when you look at the the
behavior of the right
there is no comparison between the right
and the left in terms of how much
rioting has occurred I mean the left
it's their go-to as soon as this
information got leaked we know they were
going to be threatening we knew they
were going to be threatening violence
immediately
I feel like the locations are points of
vulnerability within the within the
institutions and like
we put so much faith and trust in in
these people at these institutions like
the president of Harvard or the Supreme
Court Justices that if they get tweaked
or or bribed or something the entire or
if they leak something the entire system
falters that in social media um
Administration we have a thing called
trustless systems where you don't have
to trust that someone has your back or
that someone's going to make the right
choice the system is in plain view
everyone knows what's happening it's
automatic uh and I think maybe that our
government needs trustless systems as
well I think uh you know just going back
to my point how the institutional uh The
Establishment left and money on the left
View
the the existing structure as an
institution like the Washington Post is
the institution of Journalism whereas
the right wants to restore the actual
institution of Journalism and I think
those are different World Views where if
you can understand how many on the left
or liberals or Or democrats think you'll
better understand what their arguments
are that's that's kind of my point when
they said the rights try to destroy our
institutions it's like well think what
what must they mean Harvard University
not education they they like their their
you know archaic structures but I think
you know for us who believe in freedom
and liberty we like the idea of
education and education can come from
anywhere for me came from going online
and reading free information from
various you know professors or news
outlets and not formal education yeah I
don't think they're trying to destroy
the system of education system but maybe
the public schooling system the Dewey
set up in like the early 1900s where
they're creating these like Factory
workers and and War basically soldiers
are getting people ready to raise their
hand and only speak when they're spoken
to I think a lot of people are done with
that they want school choice they want
to learn online you know Phoenix
University was really groundbreaking in
the early 2000s I think it was you get
your degree online
there's a basic difference between the
way conservatives and progressives
approach politics in general the way
like the down to the level of what they
think the purpose and point of politics
is right to a progressive I mean it's
built into their name
and this is true of liberals as well
just that the purpose of politics is to
get us somewhere that there are certain
things that either need to be fixed or
improved or achieved whatever it is and
the purpose of politics is our means of
coming together to achieve or fix or
these things
and conservatives don't see it that way
conservatives have a much more tragic
view of History they look around and say
this we're not we're not going to some
final destination in America the goal of
politics you know politics is is much
more like uh the relations between
family members to conservatives that the
point of this is to make sure that we're
all still friends tomorrow that's the
only point to politics is to make sure
that we are all still friends tomorrow
and that we can come together to like
deal with things as they arise and you
know you're going to get very different
approaches to institutions when that's
the case right progressives can look at
it and say the point here is to get to
that place where this social justice aim
is achieved or whatever it is and if if
an institution seems to be slowing that
down
scorched Earth I mean that institution
is in the way whereas a conservative
says no no that maintaining that
institution's credibility so that we're
not all killing each other tomorrow
instead of working through our
institution that's the point I was
thinking about that too I was like uh
there's got to be rules that we all
agree to play by but that doesn't apply
to the progressive worldview the Press
of world view has been and and I'll just
throw it to the late David Graber where
I started to think about these ideas
when he said that elements of the left
have embraced the fascistic tenet there
is no truth but power and you take a
look at what many on the right would
call a double standard and James Lindsay
I think it's James Lindsay he said there
is no double standard if it's good for
the revolution it's good if it's bad for
the revolution it's bad that's that
that's how you end up seeing
contradictory Concepts like you must be
vaccinated regardless of your own body
and abortion my body my choice they then
act like conservatives of the Hypocrites
when in reality they just don't know
what conservatives are arguing whereas
conservatives are outright saying it's
not your body it's the other body a
dress from the argument from that point
if you want to have a conversation but
they're not so you know ultimately I
think for me I wonder what are the rules
to the to the to the system we're in so
that I can make sure we don't come at
each other and go nuts right and it
doesn't seem like it matters because the
rules for as you pointed out for the
progressives is to accomplish their
social justice goals social justice
goals where everyone else is kind of uh
for the most part conservatives but I
think you know whatever the factions
really end up being libertarian or
otherwise is um how do we live together
and survive this this catastrophe I
guess yeah I definitely think there's
truth in what you're saying the left has
a much more hegelian approach to their
view of History they see it as this this
process and the structure that is
building towards its ultimate end and
even that I think like from a you know a
metaphysical Christian worldview there's
truth in but I think conservatives as
you have said do have this more tragic
view of History it's more or less we are
teetering on the brink it's not as if we
are just guaranteed that tomorrow is
going to be better than today this could
all fall off if we try to try like
change the system in in the wrong way
I want to pull up this story here we
have from wusa9
group to hold vigil outside Supreme
Court Justice Samuel alito's home in
response to potential Roe v Wade
overturn the group plans to host a vigil
near alito's home starting at 7 30 PM
blah blah blah a vigil oh a vigil so
they already went to Kavanaugh's house
which is illegal and now they're going
to alito's house which is illegal but
don't worry it's a vigil what a protest
a vigil so the law says the uh the U.S
code you cannot parade or pick it in
front of a judge's house I'm simplifying
it but I think it makes sense the court
precedent or the legal precedent is that
due process Injustice
supersedes your right to free speech
because without those process processes
you can't have free speech so in this
instance people should not be going to
the homes of these justices but uh
anyone want to take a bet as to when or
if any of these people will get charged
with any kind of crime
shaking your head already everybody well
let me tell you if any of them do get uh
if any of them do get charged we're
going to see politicians tweeting out
the link to the GoFundMe to get them
bailed out yeah so this is a vigil the
definition is uh the act of keeping
awake at times when sleep is customary
so they're just going to go sit and stay
awake all night outside his house no
they're screaming if they're screaming
then it's it's a protest right right
it's it's semantic games manipulation
exactly data
well we already know that jensaki has no
negative words to say about these
protesters she's like well people
sometimes feel very passionate oh yeah
they felt passionate on January 6 and
you have a very different view of that
well I mean there's a January 6 is
different from showing up someone's
house but jungle someone's house is
overt terrible worse in some ways worse
in some ways in many ways actually but
jenseki did walk this back she came out
and she was like she tweeted it's
probably not even her it's like some
intern tweeting like send out a message
and she was just like violence can never
be tolerated and people should feel safe
it's like I missed the part gen where
you included don't go to to the homes of
these justices which they're doing
so I think uh I was I was talking about
this earlier
a lot of people say it's worse now than
it's ever been but then people like to
point out the assassination attempts of
the past and the Weather Underground you
know the weathermen and the bombings and
stuff and the death I think back then we
had acute spikes of of uh political
extremism and today we have a low
consistent rumbling of extremism which
is worse it's Death By A Thousand Cuts
the way I explain it is if we in the
past had an assassination attempt that
would be like someone taking a Pixar
pickaxe to the whole of your ship boom
they punch a hole in it the water's
spraying through and you're like quick
we better patch this hole up and
everyone panics and you rush and you
patch the hole up today it's a thousand
small holes and you can't patch them up
fast enough it is death by a Thousand
Cuts so this low level rumbling that is
affecting every level of government
that's consistent I mean I'll put it
this way I've been saying for how long
tensions are escalating potential Civil
War or Strife or whatever some kind of
some kind of hyperpolarization then
Geographic polarization and then we get
a story about the overturning of Road
heavyweight when I even said before the
story came out that I think abortion
could be a catalyst for another civil
war and not just me Stephen Marsh said
it he's the guy who wrote the book the
next civil war and now sure enough it
drops they're going to overturn it
they're holding firm with the latest
leaks people are already starting to
protest in front of Justice's homes law
students are defying the idea of the
sanctity of the Court how could we
how are we going to pull this together
and get past this in any meaningful way
it's really hard to re-establish
deterrence once it's been lost right and
that deals like in the international
arena with military strategy whether
it's law enforcement or just basic norms
and ethics once one side you know it's
like that it's like that driver that
everybody hates who just kind of
realizes that I can actually just cut
everybody off and I can just cut across
traffic and make turns as long as I
don't get caught by it might be
inconveniencing everybody else but I'm
going to get to where I want to go
quicker than anybody else and he
realizes maybe on some level that if
everybody started doing that then
nobody's getting anywhere that they're
trying to go but he knows that the good
faith of those other people means that
they're not going to do it so he can get
away with it and he gets there and once
you have kind of allowed that to
metastasize and become normal for
certain people or even you know it can
it can spread I mean the real
frightening thing that people have been
talking about for a long time is that
what happens when the right starts
acting this way now they have a you know
there are reasons that they wouldn't
ideologically maybe there are also
obviously if you see January 6 there are
law enforcement reasons why they
wouldn't do it they get treated very
differently but if they just decided to
ignore that stuff and they started
responding to things violently and they
started showing up to judge's homes they
didn't like at that point
you've lost control of and the only way
to regain control is to probably use in
a pretty extraordinary amount of force
because you have a bunch of people who
don't think that you're going to do it
it would I don't think I don't think I
could solve it if the the federal
government or law enforcement cracks
down on the left and the right it would
just
exacerbate the hyperpolarization so you
have January 6. it's bad I mean people
are not variety the people who
mindlessly trespassed when the cops
opened the door for them shouldn't have
in my opinion been charged because these
are the magomimas already one guy got
his his charges dropped because the
judge was like the cops let you in what
am I supposed to do about that there's
going to be a lot more like that but
there are a lot of violent people who
should be charged so so that's bad you
see people who are facing solitary
confinement people who have been locked
up for over a year for this
then you look at the left you had the
Insurrection on January 20th 2017 where
hundreds of people were running through
the streets smashing things starting
fires torched a limousine these people
not only were had their charges dropped
the city was forced to pay out to them
in a lawsuit now you can chalk up a lot
of this to the fact that they've been
organized the left has organizational
power and collectivist power they've
been dealing with for a long time
but when you see the FBI agents going to
Bubba Wallace's I think that's his name
right the NASCAR guy over a garage Paul
wrote yeah but but but then you see
these people showing up to judge's homes
and there's no law enforcement action or
the people who who uh you know were
throwing firebombs at Federal buildings
some of which have been charged mind you
but charged but many who haven't it is
lopsided the right gets angry and says
we have no justice if the right starts
acting out which they did on January 6
and then the boot comes down on them
which it did you can you which what you
have done is you have struck through the
heart confidence in the American system
if there is no justice for me then
what's the point of participation
yeah well and so you mentioned that
there were certain individuals there who
basically had the doors open for them by
the police they walked through I think a
large section of the country knows that
at this point they also know that there
were people who didn't engage in any
kind of misconduct of any sort who were
put on trial so for example we had uh
Marjorie Taylor green is a fantastic
example who was I believe they were
trying to smear her as an
insurrectionist and actually get her
charged so that she could not run in her
state so the idea is to get people who
would otherwise protest peacefully or be
involved in you know trying to bring
about Civic change to just stay home so
long as they have a certain perspective
and of course that perspective is a
conservative one I want to bring up this
uh op-ed from over at timcast.com from
Josie the redhead libertarian she writes
if your pro-abortion after viability and
ever wondered if you would have been an
abolitionist I have some bad news for
you she makes an interesting point about
uh Roe v Wade and and Casey and that
basically Roe actually did entertain the
conversation around viability quote as
is from the from Ruby White as we have
intimated above it is reasonable and
appropriate for a state to decide that
at some point in time a potential human
life becomes significantly involved the
woman's privacy is no longer soul and
any right of privacy she possesses must
be measured accordingly and according to
Roe the 14th right to privacy Clause is
not absolute regarding pregnancy
although the results are divided most of
these courts have agreed that the right
of privacy however based is Broad enough
to cover the abortion decision that the
right nonetheless is not absolute and is
subject to some limitations and that at
some point the state's interests as to
protection of Health Medical standards
and prenatal life become dominant we
agree with this with this approach Jose
Wright so once again according to Roe we
have a clear understanding that a baby
is a baby at viability and it's fair for
states to regulate proposed termination
if they so choose
we also have a clear understanding
thanks to Roe that a mother's personhood
may not be absolute at that point in
some states and it's fair for states to
regulate proposed termination of a baby
if they so choose Roe had limited
abortion in the first trimester but
thanks to planned paranoid V Casey that
part of Roe was overturned so states can
already do what they want barring
absolute bands of the practice emotional
augments aside this is an extreme
unpopular and highly unlikely outcome no
matter how many legislators legislators
co-sponsor the bill in terms of property
rights historically people in some
states rejected the idea that they did
not have ownership over another human
even when the laws in other states said
yes this person is a human here when
they believed a separate human belonged
to them that this separate human was
less than human and that they could do
with that human as they pleased but by
no hyperbole that was slavery
here's my here's my my thoughts on this
we mentioned last week
almost as as far almost every instance I
could think of when there has been an
attempt to expand personhood
constitutional rights to a group of
people that has ultimately played out
and we've seen that actually with the
Trans argument States across the country
are now entertaining uh gender identity
as a protected class even at the federal
level in many ways they're doing it so
this happens why would babies be the one
exception to this tendency throughout
history in which case it seems that the
only likely outcome is going to be
abortion becoming banned based on
historical trends
I mean it's it's gender is a protected
class is a slippery slope because you
can if someone's able to choose their
gender at will and then gain a
protection of some sort legally that's
complete Insanity
so I don't know it's happening I think
if we're talking about viability baby
viability and as viability is getting
less and less it's getting shorter and
shorter like now a five-month-old baby
can be born into an incubator and lived
there for three months and then as it
matures but if the I don't know if
that's really considered viability
because if the plug comes out then the
baby dies and like
well it's a it's an interesting question
it's um if the baby can survive
independent of a mother I mean there are
people who their kidneys fail and they
need dialysis but they're still
considered viable human beings so the
issue is as technology progresses
viability will extend all the way to day
one I'd imagine eventually in fact day
Zero we'll probably be able to we've
already grown I think sheep in bags so
certainly the same can be done for
humans it's just an ethical question of
you know not we should not do that so I
think works that's that's like a step of
like they might start harvesting women's
eggs in ovulation because they are
viable that's crazy psycho you can't do
that well no there's yeah there's a
difference between an egg and a Zion
like if they cannot allow it to well the
difference is it's unfertilized but
doesn't mean enters and you have like a
completely unique set of human DNA I
don't think that there's anyone who
argues the only people who argue that an
egg cell is equivalent to a zygote or
pro-choicers who are trying to straw man
pro-lifers what about like birth birth
control why is the church so against
birth control uh because the purpose of
human sexuality is unity and procreation
and birth control perverts one of those
purposes it's not because there is an
act of murder which occurs which is the
uh which is what we see with abortion
it's for very different reasons so when
we talk about viability I'm just
concerned about the technological aspect
of the viability I get it like if the
Mom's not around the baby's gonna die
until it's like 11 you know maybe a
child can't take care of something but
if you're talking about a breathing
machine that's a different story but I
think I think this question of viability
plays exactly into what I was thinking
last week with the inevitability of
abortion being banned if technology
progresses to the point where a baby is
viable the moment of conception through
an artificial womb and there's a
question in the in actually in row about
at what point viability makes this life
form a person under the Constitution and
worthy of protection if their initial
assessment was well by the second
trimester you've got you've got a baby
with a heartbeat and a brain and all
that stuff so it's it's rights are now
in play here
well then if the baby is viable from Day
Zero the moment of conception then why
would we ever allow abortion at that
point once technology gets to that point
it seems like I'll put it this way the
question of trans rights only exists
because of the invention the iso the
isolation of hormones before we actually
knew what hormones were and how to get
them there there were people who
identified as trans but there was no
hormone replacement therapy now that we
have that we have a question
constitutionally about how far this can
go and ultimately we're seeing states
starting to enact gender identity
protections technology is going to do
the same thing for human life in terms
of abortion I think the end result is
abortion gets banned I've always
fantasized about some future scenario
where they actually isolate the gauging
the gene that makes you homosexual and
then conservatives start aborting all
their gay babies and then you have all
the people on the left actually coming
out and protesting against abortion and
trying to ban it I mean
I honestly I don't think conservatives
would do that I don't either yeah I
don't well is there there's not actually
a gay gene I don't think no I'm thinking
oh yeah I uh I've been workshopping this
Theory and you guys are welcome to
disagree with me but one of the reasons
that human infants are born and it's so
difficult is because their heads are
huge and the reason that they're born so
early is because unlike baby giraffes
and baby elephants we don't just get
squeezed out on the Savannah and start
running immediately because we have huge
brains this is part of the reason why
you could potentially argue that a
three-year-old child is not viable
because if you leave a three-year-old
child to its own devices it will die in
relatively short order it will starve
it's unable to feed itself or whatever
or be Raised by Wolves oh yeah exactly I
mean that's awesome it's happened
exactly no one start uh start a city
called Rome
I also the viability is a very bizarre
way of determining when a person should
get rights for a number of reasons but I
think most importantly because
one of the entire like if not almost the
entire reason that we recognize rights
politically is to protect the weak from
the strong so the more vulnerable a
person is the more necessary it is to
extend rights to them so to look at
viability and say they're actually
particularly vulnerable at this point so
we're not going to extend the right to
life to them is completely
self-defeating it's a luxurious way of
looking at it in like tribal Society old
war Society the most vulnerable will be
killed off immediately because they're
going to hold the tribe back and get it
killed exact their rights were not
recognized but we don't want to live in
a society where somebody is killed
because they're quote unquote holding us
back or because they require more
resources or because they can't produce
as much and Ian this is not Sparta no
that's right
you can't do it aggressively because the
joke is it's not Sparta yeah this is not
Sparta we don't put our children the
baby would be born like put in the woods
yeah for like a day and if it didn't
survive like it was weak I guess
viability maybe is can the baby breathe
on its own
after you suction out its lungs can it
just lay there there are people there
are people with no lungs there are
people who have lung damage and they get
put on special machines so like for a
healthy baby not for a not for one with
a divorce but like a healthy fully
formed maybe at what stage of its
gestation can it start to breathe on its
own there there are there are people who
are born
um missing certain vital organs and we
we find ways for them to survive and
live but those are the that's some I
mean specifically for like healthy term
babies that are five months or four
months I don't think that's I don't
think you can Define viability based on
the criteria well if you have like a
loved one on a machine and they can't
breathe you can pull the plug and if you
have a guy with a pacemaker or you have
someone with uh with insulin shots like
come on that's not an argument they're
they're a diabetic people who have
insulin pumps Bluetooth
with tubes going into their bellies and
that machine is keeping them well they
can make the choice for themselves it's
the people that can't make whatever
babies and brain people that have brain
no brain basically they can't choose
from themselves so other people have to
decide are they going to pull the plug I
know people decide are they gonna afford
the thing I just I don't think you can
Define by I don't think viability is a
criteria for rights or anything like
that I just don't see it well that's I
mean you can pull the plug on someone
that's in a vegetable State you can pull
the plug on a diabetic
if they're unconscious maybe no no a
six-year-old does not get insulin you've
got to provide it to them and make sure
you're the one I think that's murder if
you do if you if you don't give your
six-year-old it's not it's insulin and
it dies if you have if you have a baby
on a ventilator you shut the ventilator
off that's murder if it can't if it
doesn't have brain access it can't make
that decision so someone else's a six
year old can't make the decision either
well technically they can they have
brain activity I'm just talking about
people without brain activity or like
babies in the womb that where you can't
communicate with them there are people
who experiences loss of uh brain
function and go into Comas for very long
periods of time and they recover so it
like the if you unplug them you're
killing them and and the challenge
morally is that sometimes we're like is
this person going to recover and people
have to make a hard decision about
whether we say it's time or it's not and
the scary thing is sometimes after long
periods of time years people do recover
so do you want to be the person pulling
the plug but my point is it's legal to
pull the plug in those situations and
when if it's someone that's healthy it's
not legal to have them killed okay
that's an unborn child is healthy and
they're trying developing they're just
not at a stage of development where they
can make choices so that's a different
scenario so in in this in the
environment of if they're taken out of
the womb at four and a half months
they're not going to be healthy but if
if you remove them from the womb yeah I
mean they could be per they're perfectly
healthy at that stage of development but
yeah but relative to their environment
but and that's also part of why you
can't remove them I mean you can't
remove someone from an environment where
they're perfectly healthy and sit and
say you know what I'm not going to give
you the treatment that you need given
the fact that I just stripped you from
the environment that's good for you I
think the legal argument would then be
oh you can remove them so long as you
replace 100 with what you've taken from
them right so if we get to the point
technologically where a baby can at
whatever stage be it one week two weeks
or even one day be placed in an
artificial womb I think the termination
of the baby becomes illegal outright now
abortion in some sense like the removing
of the baby from the wind I think
becomes overtly legal at all stages at
that point because then the baby will
always survive right I truly believe if
they do that one day one you can take it
out and put it in a machine that it's
gonna lead to people harvesting eggs and
saying you cannot ovulate it is illegal
for you to obviously no come on man now
that's that's absurd I know it it sounds
absurd but we'll see what would the
motivation be well I mean yeah maybe the
CCP might do crazy stuff like if we
start legislating that they have to give
this one day old thing to the to the to
the world and then like why not day Zero
why not day negative one because the
point would be when life begins at
conception but those eggs are alive
they're just not human fertilized
they're not but it's living tissue it's
it's
when when an egg is fertilized again
When a Man Loves a Woman yes life begins
a conception and egg is is is a
component of the creation of life but it
is not the life
well it's a it's a it's a piece of
living meat or whatever it is it's the
egg itself I think the question is
there's no potential there's no
potential life so that's what it is is
potential life now only when it meets
with the sperm and then it becomes so
like I got eggs in the chickens they
said in the Shelf until they rotten
explode yeah there's there's no
potential there unless they're
fertilized oh I disagree and even if
they're fertilized they require specific
conditions but anyway let's let's let's
move on to I think we'll just I mean
what do you think you've been listening
well I think this is an obviously an
incredibly complex moral question right
which is why the I think the
conservative perspective on this is not
to seek a maximalist position trying to
ban abortion or drive it back to the
first day after fertilization but to
recognize the complexity of it recognize
that they were probably irreconcilable
views that people are going to have and
allow Alabama and New York to have
different abortion laws that they work
out through the discourse in their
Democratic processes you know it's I I
think it's it's going back to the idea
of like conservative the way
conservatives look at Politics as
something that is that we engage in to
make sure that we all wake up tomorrow
we're not killing each other I think
that's like in that sense the
conservative way of way of approaching
it I mean because we like if if the way
humans gave birth
was a woman got fertilized and then the
egg like popped out and then you put it
in a plastic bag in the fridge and then
it grew into a human like after that
that was just how humans you know
evolved say to uh then we wouldn't allow
abortion at all you would have it there
in the bag that came out the first day
and we'd be like you know no you can't
flush that thing down the toilet we'll
take it or whatever and but you can't
you can't do that to it this question
only becomes really relevant because
you're dealing with a very real
rights claim you know a woman's right to
control what goes on with her body that
is a however anybody feels about
abortion you have lots of people I think
libertarian types maybe who are
anti-abortion but they're very like they
want to end the drug war because they
think that a person wants to put
something into their body then they
should be able to it's it's bodily
autonomy it's a real argument that you
know that that conservatives I think
have have more recently done a better
job of of dealing with but it's
something that you know it does have to
be dealt with I mean you're you're
talking about uh you know
just basic basic rights when you're
talking about somebody's ability to
control what happens with their body I
wanna I wanna jump to this uh this post
here from our good friends over at two X
chromosomes on Reddit
a top post says delete your dating apps
no more women on dating apps is the only
language men speak plus the less time
you spend on Tinder the more time you
can spend protesting at the courthouse
edit to all men coming on here crying
about how you're against us of course
you are that's the point F off you know
what I love about this the kind of guy
that's going to go to these women and be
like please don't leave the dating app
but I'm I'm I'm for uh abortion I'm an
ally I'm an ally it's like a good guy
they're they're just angering their own
side
these these men who are doing what they
want meanwhile conservatives are like no
way don't don't delete your dating apps
well it I mean look it just goes to show
you that like feminists don't like male
feminists either
yeah I mean who does who doesn't no but
I think it's funny that this is a
consistent argument so we have uh this
one post says I deleted mine a while ago
but before this leak I was just starting
to consider trying again nope effort
I'll stick to a vibrator in my
imagination Mr Buzzy can't get me
pregnant can't lie about not having an
STI doesn't care if I also see Mr rabbit
or look at a Hitachi at the store
yo this is there's there's
what's the right word I don't want to
say
they're crazy
but they're kind of crazy to not
understand the Nuance in what's
happening here that they can they don't
know what conservatives think about this
they've probably never even spoken to
someone who is anti-abortion about
what's really going on and why they
think it and the fact that these women
probably live in blue States I'm just I
genuinely do not understand it I don't I
don't believe they actually know what
they're arguing for or against do you
think that's what they're doing outside
the Supreme Court Justice houses they're
like the leading Tinder they're like
look Kevin on now you're not gonna see
me you're gonna be able to swipe
[Laughter]
there are so many examples of the left
circling back and coming back to
traditional like social positions
through like a back door you know I
remember a few months ago I was
listening to Jordan Peterson interview
this child psychologist from Canada
apparently he's a he's big Wiggy one
like the Nobel Prize of child psychology
or whatever and he was uh he deals with
um designing State interventions for
children in disadvantaged homes and
studies like how this affects their
anti-social Behavior their violent
behavior and stuff as they get older and
so he's describing how all these
different programs would work and he's
describing this one in the middle
he says so what we'll do is we'll have a
social worker that'll come into the
house you know of a single mother who
maybe you know doesn't have any
experience doesn't know really know like
how to handle certain things when the
kid does this or does that how they're
trying to communicate and the social
worker will be there who has this
experience who can kind of tell them
like oh this is what the kid is trying
to do and like kind of walk them through
these processes and Peterson kind of
pauses for a minute he goes
well that sounds like a grandmother and
it's like then I realized everything he
had been describing were just
bureaucratic replacements for all of the
things that have been lost over the last
several decades and that was one of them
and this is kind it just sort of happens
that way well have you I want to mention
there's also an additional component to
this you're correct that the left will
end up in a roundabout way rediscovering
some form of social conservatism or
traditionalism and then at that point
the right starts defending whatever it
is the left was pushing for 50 years ago
and so historically before we just had
these like isolated nuclear families
people did tend to live with their older
relatives their older aunts or uncles or
you know parents were still living with
them helping them with the children and
now we're at a point where people are
putting their father or mother in a
nursing home when it's when it's
unnecessary just because they don't want
to deal with them and they're calling
themselves pro-family conservatives have
you seen now what the far right is
pushing this is here they want this this
this insane meme of rejecting modernity
and returning to tradition
you're going to be shocked by what I'm
going to show you in a tweet from Jack
passobic he says remember what they took
from you and this shocking image it's
Pizza Hut and the Pac-Man machine book
it the Red Cups the little dinosaurs
Care Bears the Pizza Hut lamp so Jack
has been going on this what is it Pizza
Hut nationalism he loves Pizza Hut where
it's like pizza used to be great and now
it's basically I'm kidding by the way
about the far right you know stuff the
uh oh the weird Pizza claymation or
whatever it was he was telling the story
how he went he took his kids to Pizza
Hut because he remembered what it was
like when he was a kid and it was just
trash there was garbage everywhere it
was messy it was like what is this and
you know I'll say he's obviously joking
to quite a bit but there is a bit of
Truth into what he's saying that there
were things that we had that were nice
that are now gone that have fallen apart
and you mentioned it was a bureaucratic
replacement
uh Daryl you're talking about a
grandmother and the state's replacement
I kind of feel like that's where we're
going where
Pizza still exists but you go inside and
it's a dry shell lacking flavor lacking
anything other than you sit down here's
your pizza get out
it's the same thing happened after the
1960s you go to like 1973 is when George
Lucas who was part of the new director's
Movement Like These rebellious Dennis
Hopper like all these new director types
in the late 60s Easy Rider all that
George Lucas in 1973 makes American
Graffiti which is sort of it began the
the sort of 1950 The Cult of 1950s
Nostalgia right it's I don't know if you
guys have ever seen it it's like as much
of a stereotypical kind of 1950s
childhood movies you can imagine and he
was open about like why he did it he
said because everything that comes out
now is depressing it sucks and for like
the last several years every film that's
come out has just told us how bad we are
how evil the war is how etc etc and I
just didn't want any more of that and I
don't think a lot of other people do too
and it started that Trend Happy Days
came out like a year or two later after
that and for us I think
we're kind of going through a similar
thing in the 80s and early 90s are kind
of our 1950s you know there's That 70s
Show which was the late 90s right yeah
and the crazy thing is I think is it is
this true that uh yeah yeah That 70s
Show was closer to the time period when
it was released than we are to the 90s
now ugh yeah
so they're actually they're doing a
reboot I think aren't they doing a
reboot that 90s show and it's about oh
yeah
they're trying to do that 80s Show do
you remember that yeah that was Oh I
thought you're gonna say no no but I
think it might just be that people have
Nostalgia for when they were kids and
they always thought it was better that
and it looks like yum food brands bought
I don't know if they bought Pizza Hut
Taco Bell and KFC and 90. basically This
tricon Global restaurants Incorporated
in 97 1997. it came out of PepsiCo it's
kind of obfuscated as to who owns what
here but I think they all got merged I
just advertised I just got to point out
that I have fond memories of going to
Pizza when I was a kid when you would
get the book it thing you get the little
wheel or whatever with all the things
you win and you go in and you get like a
little pizza because you read the books
or whatever and uh
Jack is obviously making a you know he's
being silly about it but there are there
are people on the left that are really
upset about Jack's statements about
pizza that genuinely confuse me it was
fun going to Pizza we were kids
everything else is meant to be more
silly in a joke but talking about how
you know we the things we did back then
we don't do anymore and it kind of sucks
and times won't stay the same forever
but it's just funny how angry they got
well people they hate fun yeah
people I disagree I think they're
addicted to it people have Nostalgia for
their childhoods all the time obviously
because your childhood was the time
before everything got so complicated but
that is also true like on a real
societal level in in this particular age
you know as well like I don't know how
old all of you guys are exactly but I'm
like right at that age where I was right
in that sweet spot where I lived enough
of my life about 20 years before I ever
really got on the internet I kind of
knew about it and I would you know wow
I'm 40. oh okay right right at that age
where you have enough experience of the
world what it was like before everybody
had smartphones and everything and yet
you're young enough that you can just
you can pick it up and you can learn it
and you can kind of get fully integrated
and you know it has uh it's radically
changed things and I think it's made
things more complicated these kids today
will not know the joy of hearing the
phone ring and racing your sibling full
speed to try and answer it first
or
um
be watching something on television and
having to like go grab your snack during
the commercial break yeah actually to be
honest though that is coming back to a
lot of streaming services but I think
real quick there's a funny post where
someone said the kids today will never
know the joy of rushing to the kitchen
to grab snacks during a commercial break
and your sibling yelling it's on that's
right and then it was on Tumblr someone
said they couldn't just pause it and
then someone said Oh My Sweet Summer
Challenge oh but that's hilarious but I
will say I I do think there's more to it
than Nostalgia so you you mentioned the
filmmakers of the 70s and I've heard it
said that part of why Star Wars was so
successful and I'm not really much of a
fan but I've heard it argued part of why
it was successful is because in that era
in the 60s and 70s so much of what was
being produced was depressing but also
sort of morally ambiguous they didn't
want to have a clear-cut good guy bad
guy narrative but Star Wars leaned very
heavily into that and now you see a lot
of fans arguing online on Twitter that
we need to have the gray Jedi and this
series needs to be more about moral
ambiguity than know a huge part of what
made it successful was the fact that
they were willing to draw clear lines
between what's good and bad it was that
kind of a story of Christ Star Wars the
first one Luke was fighting against the
empire like Jesus did and he had magic
powers like Christ did and stuff like
that it was a hero's journey yeah the
hero's journey is very much but I want
to make a point as a meme where the NPC
guy says who radicalized you and then
the chat guy says I'm just a normal
person from 10 years ago a bunch of
people on the left were like see that
proves you're conservative and I'm just
like bro
Top surgery for 14 year old girls
there's a big difference between being
Progressive and just like having no
control and my point was the Eugenics
movement of the progressives in the
1900s died and was considered amoral or
immoral and unethical just because you
think just because the progressives
think they're going to win doesn't mean
their ideas are good and just because
you oppose them doesn't mean you're a
conservative you you technically I'd
argue if you're a progressive you hold
values from the early 1900s that sounds
a bit concernable artificial
insemination is eugenics I brought this
up before and people messaged me we're
like thank you that kind of got glazed
over well unless you mate with the very
first of sexually available person you
meet then you're kind of a eugenicist
right well but I mean if we're already
selectivity at all is like you're doing
a little bit but hold on look at look at
women going to sperm banks and then
getting a catalog of of of of the males
to choose from right so I understand the
argument that like a woman will make her
make her choices but Eugenics I think is
better defined by preventing people from
procreating yeah and so there are I
think it's choosing who they procreate
with whether that's no one genetics was
about good breeding the idea was that
you would have the best possible
breeding now obviously men and women
both select their main rights so when a
woman goes to a sperm bank and she's
like here's the catalog of men it's like
a guy wearing a suit it's like IQ 145
and he's a six-figure salary that's it's
an extreme version of female selection
which I don't it's like okay it's a
weird modernity thing but I think
Eugenics is really sour and bad when it
was like we must prevent this group from
having kids or terminate the children
that may have these traits yeah that's
the ugly head of eugenics that's for
sure
mate selection I think is normal and
fine you know a woman's gonna be like
honestly dude you're like but I don't
want to have a baby with you it's like
well that's life it used to be like they
would shoot the parents would choose who
the kids married for most of History I
think and relatively and and we've we
found that to be wrong you know it we we
as we we did away with eugenics in terms
of parents choosing who their kids would
marry and dowrys and all that and then
we also decided you should stop at
people from having kids which is what
Margaret Sanger wanted to do well like
she she I mean I'm look whatever you
want to argue about from the left they
want to say she wasn't racist fine but
she did want to she did argue literally
and fought very hard to stop certain
people from having kids yeah no she was
absolutely racist and she was eugenicist
but I wouldn't argue that arranged
marriage is eugenics because they were
not selecting the partner for their
child necessarily on the basis of
something like genetic fitness it could
be this is a morally virtuous person and
so I want my child to marry them or the
dad is Rich yeah right it depended on
the choice of the parent they could be
like I want you to have the most
beautiful uh wife but usually it was for
money I mean when it came to the royal
families they did not care for genetics
at all so I wouldn't call that Eugenics
yeah it's about
um land rights and stuff they want the
wife to have ownership like she's going
to get the the county of Brussels so I'm
going to marry her to the my son who has
the kingdom of England consolidate power
all these Kings in World War One were
cousins yeah it was yeah so that's what
I hear before we go too far away from
this Pizza Hut thing yum food brands was
spun up to purchase KFC Taco Bell and
Pizza Hut and the top owners have yum
food brands are Vanguard black rocks
State Street at four percent do it day
row price Associates dude dude I just
want to when people say that Meme reject
modernity Embrace tradition the one
thing I will say
I mentioned before when you're a tourist
in key parts of the world and you come
to the famous downtown area of some City
in some Far Away country and it's
McDonald's Starbucks Mochi Hard Rock
Cafe you just throw up a little bit
you're just like what is this is this is
this it the world will have nothing left
to offer us yeah there's no Adventure
there's no there's no diversity
you know the left talks about diversity
all day and night but I tell you when I
went to the Bahamas and I was like I
guess I'll go to Starbucks I'm like
that's not fun the doubt the weird thing
is when you're in another country and
they only have like little like coffee
shops where they're making coffee and
they're burning the bean and it doesn't
taste and you're like oh this is all
then you see a Starbucks it's like an
oasis in the desert and you're like I
can get a standardized thing that I know
what it's going to taste like thank God
and you go there and you get a real
coffee just exactly like it always
tastes no that's the upside of this dude
standardization yeah yeah yeah like I'm
gonna I'll tell you this if I am in some
small far away country and their burgers
are weird and gross I still will not go
to McDonald's not McDonald's Starbucks
no make Starbucks
Starbucks cold brew actually they have
quality because I've been Starbucks
corporate McDonald's though I don't like
Starbucks I don't think a Starbucks is
fast food really I don't ever eat their
food really so I wanted to say before we
move on for this Pizza Hut thing I would
think that Nostalgia would be the one
thing that would be truly bipart Artisan
that everybody of about the same age
would really resonate with but you were
talking about the sinews that hold
people together at a very low level I
think this is one of those things the
fact that we can't even agree on some
kind of fond childhood memory is kind of
crushing to watch like that's
distressing that we don't even agree
about that what is wrong with us I
I think uh
I think childhood today is being
destroyed on purpose I think we as as
Millennials have a kind of shared
experience in these cultural phenomena
from when we were little like BookIt and
Pizza Hut so when Jack pesobic posts the
Red Cups and the little pan pizzas many
of us go I remember that even if it was
just one time you went because your
school gave you those little things like
if you if you read enough books the
teacher would sign off and then Pizza
would give you a little free pizza so
you'd get it that's a shared cultural
experience now what do we have well
shared cultural experience is all like
the weird stuff kids are being taught in
schools Marvel movies yeah I was I was
just about to bring that up I mean
childhood has in some way been been
redistributed to adults so we've
extended adolescence as far as we
possibly could I mean maybe not as far
as we possibly could we're probably
pushing to extend it even further I've
been saying this they want they they are
preventing adulthood that's yeah that's
what's happening whether intentional or
not puberty blockers preventing
adulthood Millennials have three percent
I think man that's one but there's a
meme going around like Millennials have
three percent of U.S wealth and Boomers
have 21 percent it's the poorest
generation in history
and uh I think it's because boomers are
living longer and I think it's because
Millennials were poorly raised yeah I
think that's a huge part of it I also
think that it's the case that when you
look at the way children are raised
today I sort of mentioned that we've
redistributed childhood right because we
prolong adolescence but on top of that
it's not as if we give two children what
was traditionally given to them so at a
very young age eight nine ten years old
a kid has handed a smartphone which is a
tool for an adult to use but they just
use it to do unrestrained irresponsible
things and then they continue to do that
until they're 30. instead of using this
tool for something productive so it's
very strange and it's a rejection of
responsibility sadly and no culture can
function once that becomes the status
quo let's pull the audience in a way
that unashamedly promotes the show smash
the like button if you think kids should
not have cell phones there you go yeah
I've been thinking a lot about this
because we talk about kids getting
access to the internet what age should
they get access to the internet and
what's it going to do to their brain to
have all that information blasted at me
and then I started thinking you know
what that happened to me when I was 26
years old I got on YouTube and people
started hitting me with all this
information so I started looking up the
Federal Reserve fiat currency the bank
of international settlements the
American war machine liberal economic
order and I'm like wow we're not I I
went insane Society classifying would
have classified me as insane I was
completely destroyed mentally and had to
rebuild what I thought I was that's
happening to kids when they're five
seven eight and it's happening to adults
when they're 60. so this internet's
danger man it's the danger zone it's a
Minefield for the mind
and we got to treat it like that yeah
and it subverts this this process of
growing up right where like we were
talking before before the show about
this plan I have for my kids where I'm
going to have like a library and there's
going to be bookshelves full of books so
that the kids grow up and they're just
used to their being books all around and
my plan is like the books at the very
bottom those are going to be kids books
you get a little higher a little higher
a little higher those are going to be
the ones where I can tell my kid you're
not ready for that yet and then they're
going to be like oh I want that book now
that's something that happened like with
all of childhood back in the days there
were things that you were not old enough
for yet that you don't get to see that
you don't get to experience that yet
you're just not old enough you're not at
that point and it creates that sort of
Yearning to mature and grow up and now
because of smartphones and just the
permissiveness of the way we raise kids
you're seven years old you can see
anything you can do anything I am
shocked and offended by what how you
described what your children will be
reading will be rating clearly the only
things they should be allowed to read
are Harry Potter and the handmaids today
handmade still come on mate still
what was that what was the joke we're
making a we're going to synthesize them
and do a reboot that lefties will really
pay money for it's going to be called
Harry handmade the hairy hands it was
like Harry handmade and The Sorcerer's
tale something like that philosophers
tell so good yeah I like this idea that
you're going to have books for your kids
I one time my dad was was telling I was
in the bathtub I was like six or
something or seven and he started to
tell me a joke and he was like ah
I'll tell you when you're older and I
was like no what he's like I'll tell you
when you're older so like and then it's
like a rite of passage when he finally
tells you you're like oh you're right
well 15 years went by and I asked him
what was that joke you were going to
tell me he's like I don't remember what
you're talking about so make sure they
get a chance to read the books when I
was little we had cable and the cable
box man I remember this is crazy had
parental lock print a lock on it four
digit code and we want whenever we
wanted to watch Biebs and Butthead my
mom had to be like only if I'm there we
could you know and and I decide you're
you're allowed to watch it because some
of those episodes it beeps and butted
not for little kids but some of them
were just hilarious yeah there's
something my dad said to me when I was
growing up which is that and he was
referring to the television but this is
the first time in human history that
people let complete strangers into their
house to teach their children things
without any kind of filter and when you
put it that way it becomes clear just
how alarming the situation is and yeah
is this Millennials doing it what do you
mean well my dad is referring no he was
referring to his own generation and the
fact that they sit their kids in front
of the television or don't police what
they're watching they don't filter any
of it and so
it's very very sad it's very sad and
there are so many horrible things kids
get into at an early age I mean we're
not just talking about bad political
theories or horrible advice children end
up seeing pornography at a very early
age and it warps them when I was in
seventh grade
we had that one kid that every you know
male friend group has who was like the
Pervert kid right and he brought a
couple of his dad's Playboys to school
one time and everybody like who found
out I was like oh my God
a couple playboys and then he got caught
by the teacher and we're like well he's
dead I mean he's clearly going to be
executed like on the playground like his
life is completely over and it's like
now today little Johnny brings a cell
phone to school and you got to explain
to your six-year-old what x y and z are
that's terrifying and instead of being
like kids shouldn't have cell phones you
have these teachers being like kids have
questions yep and we're going to answer
them and show them graphic pictures I
love it uh the the Washington posts
writing that op-ed where it's like it's
a book about being genderqueer and kids
need these stories and it's being banned
now and then Amazon's like 18 and up
only because it's got graphic depictions
of adult activities in it well and they
would not put the actual images from the
book in their publication because they
knew they were too depraved but they
they were arguing that children should
be shown those images in public schools
that's how you know they're creeps yep
because they know what's in the book and
they're lying yeah it's really
remarkable actually if you go back to
the late 60s how many of the radicals
from that era after they got done being
you fake revolutionaries went into Early
Elementary education or like went into
the educational training you have guys
like
um like Daniel Cohn bendy out in France
he was a big revolutionary 68 guy out
there and afterwards he went and opened
a kindergarten and then he wrote A
Memoir about it a few years after that
and he talked about it's like in the mid
70s talking about how you know this all
of this sexual repression is what leads
to Fascism and the authoritarian
personality and everything and so if he
caught like a couple of his kids like
fondling each other or something he
would just sit there and like talk to
him while they did it and make sure they
were comfortable sometimes they would
come up and touch him what this guy this
guy became like a politician in France
nobody cared it got brought up sometime
in the late 90s they tried to like use
it against him and nobody cared yeah you
know so I've I've mentioned this on the
show before but there's a follow by the
name or a disgusting pervert by the name
of Alfred Kinsey and he is known as the
father of the sexual Revolution he is
the father of sexology or the like the
modern scientific field of studying
human sexuality and in his published
Works he had data tables that were
collected by sexually abusing young boys
and this had been done to like over 200
miners boys under the age of 15
including infants I won't explain what
the Tata tables say on air it's really
disgusting but so much of this stuff is
completely out in the open and the
boomer generation is
comedic in a sense because I remember
growing up watching movies that The
boomer generation made about how heroic
the boomer generation was
and there's this idea that they were
these Brave revolutionaries because
their parents who had just lived through
the Great Depression and then fought in
the second world war came home and said
you know like we have some advice on how
the world works and you should listen to
us and they said screw you Mom and Dad
I'm gonna have one night stands and
listen to rock and roll and this is
considered this Really Brave and
important Revolution it was just a bunch
of spoiled children it was just a bunch
of spoiled children completely
tarnishing and squandering their
inheritance I want to bring up this uh
this tweet here
it's from me there's a tweet from
Stonewall Jackson I responded to where
he says this is so pathetic the new Star
Trek show depicts what appears to be the
January 6 protest leading to the end of
the world and the human race as we know
it I actually I I find the clip from the
new Star Trek show very interesting they
call January 6th a fight for freedom
yeah no no so um I don't know if we can
play it because you know they're very
litigious here on YouTube but he says it
started with a fight for Freedom shows
audit the vote on January 6 and then the
protests from the summer and he says It
ultimately led to the Eugenics war and
then finally World War III where
hundreds of thousands of species were
wiped out but hold on there a minute is
that not plausible
it starts with a fight for Freedom so
they describe January 6th they show kind
of crazy they would call January 6 a
fight for freedom but sure led to the
Eugenics Wars well hold on what's
happening right now Roe v Wade is being
banned and the left is going to the
homes of Supreme Court Justices and
they've thr there's a a a non-profit
product nonprit at a Malta of cocktail
thrown through its window reportedly
that's the accusation and several
pro-life pregnancy centers were
vandalized
in this show or maybe they didn't
realize it
it makes sense it's plausible in today's
day and age a Eugenics War yeah the
abortion issue I think it's kind of
poorly written because if there was
really at the second because then they
go it led to the uh which led to Civil
War which then led to World War well he
says ultimately World War ultimately
world what he would really be saying is
then China and the United States and you
talk about World War that's stuff
leading up to it is forgotten well no no
hold on I think this actually works let
me break it down for political crap
you've got January 6 a fight for Freedom
as he calls it you then have you know
people are fighting tensions are rising
Roe v Wade gets overturned and then all
of a sudden you have blue States
outright saying abortion even in
Virginia after birth and and the media
will claim it's not true but we all
heard what Northam said the baby would
be delivered resuscitated if that's what
they wanted and kept comfortable and
then the conversation would happen which
basically means what fine what's the
conversation about let's just say well
he wasn't specific Colorado Limitless no
restricted abortion could this lead to a
conflict which is about whether or not
some people should not have kids or or
should it's happening how could it how
could it then become World War III he
may be oversimplifying it but the
political conflict inside the United
States could ultimately result in a
unipolar world destabilizing China
expanding in various countries Russia
expanding in Eastern Europe the U.S
still trying to maintain unipolar
dominance and then World War III I think
it's fascinating they wrote this through
it but I will start with the point where
they describe January 6 as a fight for
Freedom yeah I think what and I'm sure
you know this I appreciate your analysis
but obviously they were trying to smear
the right more or less put it on
conservatives no no I really don't think
so you think they're trying to be
neutral in what way could you could you
he literally shows January 6th since
it's a fight for Freedom how could you
in any way say he's trying to smear them
well I think when you look at the track
record of Hollywood and their analysis
of current events they tend to come down
on the side of the left and I would also
argue that for a television show to
explicitly say they were in favor of
what happened on January 6 would
basically be sues you would have said it
started with disinformation riling up
disaffected citizens into believing
their country was stolen from them and
rioting I don't sparked a civil war no
he said a fight for free January 6
wasn't a fight there was a few people
that got into it maybe but it wasn't it
was just a protest maybe he was talking
about the feds and he's like those feds
were fighting for Freedom it does then
show Summer of Love Stuff you know so
yeah so also it's possible you know they
write the dialogue and then the editor
ends up placing certain images over the
dialogue that the writer might not have
intended but you know I kind of I think
I agree with you Ian about the point
that it's a little bit lazy so it's not
abnormal for a science fiction show
about the future to comment on current
events or at least contemporary culture
but to do it in a really over-the-top
way like this seems really lazy instead
of the crazy instead of creating an
allegory for it or having characters in
the future present a situation you might
be more detached from than the current
event they are literally showing things
that happen today and commenting on it I
think it's a ripoff of a Star Trek
episode where data asks about terrorism
because there they visit a planet where
there are terrorists and then he
mentions data says I don't understand
some elements of their conduct you know
we say it's wrong to do these things but
it's actually been quite successful for
many groups and then he mentions Mexico
Ireland and then he mentions a
fictitious 2020 you know 20 2022 or 22
20 something event Star Trek world and
basically what that data does is he asks
a question about
uh terrorism using real historical
elements and then a fictitious sci-fi
element from the future we haven't
encountered yet it seems to be the exact
same thing they're doing it's lazy it's
very lazy I mean it's video footage from
last year too which is that's why I
watched Star Trek that's why I watched
sci-fi shows about the future I want to
see video footage from last year yeah
right
laziness no but I don't know I find it
fascinating I wonder I you know
laziness or short-sightedness or like a
lack of creativity on the the aura
political underhanded move but yeah I
don't think you can I mean I haven't
seen the clip but I don't think you can
put a January 6th clip in that context
on a show without it being a political
decision I mean I think that's something
that's done on purpose yeah
absolutely well that also shows it shows
that George Floyd's right okay yeah well
but and of course this kind of thing
affects rewatchability like if you you
know people will go back and re-watch
episodes of TNG or the original series
I don't think I really don't think
people are going to be going back and
re-watching this 15 20 years from now I
I'm not watching it the first time yeah
exactly exactly they've they've just
you know what it is I don't I don't know
they they hired a bunch of people who
hate Star Trek to write Star Trek is
this the one with Stacey Abrams she made
an appearance as like the president of
the planets or something did you guys
that was Discovery I think Stacy Abrams
the the president of Earth okay
political Star Trek trash again they
have a politician you know you mentioned
this earlier we were talking before the
show about the late night TV and how
they're uh in the key demo we actually
rival some late night television shows
which is actually really bad for them
because they used to get 20 million
views and the funny thing is you
mentioned how
older people watch those shows they used
to watch it every night but now all of a
sudden they're being made fun of this is
the funny thing like Jimmy Kimmel for
instance in like the late night the
people who are who are watching CNN the
people who are watching these shows the
overall majority are are like 60 to 70
years old
and they're trying to make the politics
of these shows fit a millennial leftist
or Progressive world view and it's like
well that's not the boomer generation
so your show used to actually attract
tens of millions of people in the boomer
generation you've decided to sacrifice
all of that for Millennials who consume
digital media they should just be making
a new show they should keep that show
with older hosts to keep talking to the
older crowd that was young in the 80s
when David Letterman was in his 30s and
then they should have a new show but
they're competing for time slots which
is also archaic because people watch
stuff on YouTube at any time of day you
don't need it's stuff's on demand now
it's people industry I don't know I I
don't make a generalization about
industry being slow to adopt the hot new
thing but the entertainment industry
sure is it's they were still making me
male headshots in in like 2008 to uh
because sending a digital thing was
apparently just it was they just didn't
under it was too new so it wasn't good
are we just uh going through the natural
progression of old fogism where we're
like it was better when I was a kid yeah
I mean I'm 27 but I'm already there new
content is bad I did hear you say these
kids today remember remember uh The
Simpsons thing where Abe is talking to a
young Homer and he's like it'll happen
to you too it was like I used to be with
it but then they changed what it was not
what it is is scary to me I think it'll
happen to you I think children today are
smarter than the previous generation
um intellectually and their minds work
quicker but and that's the natural
progression of evolution but emotionally
we're experiencing some challenges
because of the disconnectedness of the
technology you know what I you know what
I was thinking though I I wonder if
that's that's true because I know kids
today are still very much passionate
about capturing small animals and
forcing them to fight each other yeah
yeah I went to I went to a we went to a
bowling alley arcade the other day and
all the kids just love forcing animals
to fight you know brutally just beat
each other and uh tons of Pokemon toys
everywhere yeah you know I grew up I
grew up with Pokemon I remember when the
when it I guess it first started the
like in America and I bought Pokemon red
on the original game boy with money I
made it my family's Cafe fa from tips
and today kids are still very much
watching Pokemon and the toys are like
the big prize at the arcade we're
Pokemon stuff
I was talking to somebody the like I
guess a couple months ago now
did you know there are Pokemon cards
that get sold for a half a million
dollars
garyvee is a big proponent he had to
show me on his phone I did not believe
him the funny thing is like
having owned so many foil first edition
Pokemon cards and then just like having
lost them or sold them now it's it's
like a laughable when I'm like that's
how much they're going for these days
wow because the printing run was so low
I don't know because look you know
Millennials are broke right Millennials
are are relatively poor so so who cares
that much about Pokemon other than
nostalgic Millennials so I guess there's
a spattering of wealthy Millennials who
are like I would like to buy a Charizard
for a million bucks it's got to just be
speculators in the market right I don't
think it's like a Pokemon fan who's like
I've got to have that car there's some
dude who's like there's like a gen Z I
mean he mowed a lot of Lawns that summer
and he needed that Pokemon card no no
think about it if you're if you're gen Z
right now it is a great bet to buy old
Pokemon cards because once the Boomers
age out and then Millennials inherit a
lot of this wealth you're gonna have a
bunch of nostalgic Rich 60 year old
Millennials and you're gonna be in your
mid-40s and you're going to be like you
want that Charizard I got it and that
hundred thousand dollars is going to be
10 million bucks that theme that you
just talked about about Millennials not
having any monies come out a couple
times and it seems like
that's one of the threads that kind of
ties everything together
politically and socially right now right
where
if you go back to like the late 60s
again people you know middle-aged people
were looking at the colleges looking at
the youth movement and they were like oh
my God like when these people take over
our society like actually go out and get
into Authority positions like we're just
I guess we're just done this is the end
of America the end of the world and of
course it turned out not to be that way
because those people got out of college
and they got jobs and bought houses and
had kids and then once you get to that
point you kind of care about what your
community is going to be like in 10
years you care about what kind of
schools your kids are going to and you'd
be that's another way of saying you
basically become a conservative in a lot
of important like dispositional ways
you look at the millennial generation
and so what happens right so every every
like 25 years or so is like when that
happens in the past you get to about 25
maybe late 20s by that point your
parents are starting to be like are you
not going to get married yet like what's
going on there was that that was the
timing of it the Millennials has had
like that that period that young person
period has had so much more room to run
because they're in their mid to late 30s
and they're not able to get married and
have kids and buy houses or create a
stable career I don't think that's it
I don't you know I've heard a lot from
Millennials where they're like we'd be
getting married and having kids if it
wasn't for this economy and I'm like I
don't believe it I just I just think
that's an excuse I think people are just
permanent children well the economy is
in a horrific State when Obama bailed
out Freddie man Fanny a family man
Freddie Mac and when we all found out we
were on fiat currency and not the gold
standard in 2007 everybody got the red
pill uh that was like oh and now we're
what are we just are we in
hyperinflation right now I don't know if
you'd call it hyperinflation but we've
just almost doubled our money supply it
is it's I'm gonna I'll call myself
outright I'm 36 I am not married I'm in
a relationship but we have no kids that
there is something about Millennials
where it just it didn't happen well but
values change to accommodate reality
right I mean like you know I just think
about I was just ahead of this curve I
guess I got lucky for that but if you're
about 35 about your age
you basically
um got out of high school 9 11 happens
we've been at War ever since you've been
anything like an adult right and
all the only politics that you've known
is people screaming at each other
calling each other Nazis and so forth
and that's it that's that's our politics
as far as since you've ever been paying
attention to politics that's what it's
been
you just get out of college and like the
year or two after you get out of college
the financial crisis hits and things are
just a waste for several years you
finally start to maybe get back on your
feet in your mid-30s and you're starting
to put something together covet hits
like this is just an incredible amount
of instability for any generation to
handle and you know the Millennials are
going to be the first generation in
American history that has a lower
standard of living than their parents do
yep and you cannot overstate I think
how significant that is right because
it's not just like oh my parents had a
house it was this big and I only get a
house it's this big what people relate
it to like what their basic standard of
what a life should look like is how
things were when they were growing up
and so you have an entire generation of
people who in the aggregate
grew up a certain way and are starting
to realize and understand that they are
going to take a step back from where
that was and that's
you know it is it's not a it's not some
like huge mystery why we get Bernie
Sanders at a time like this there's a uh
this viral video about pod housing where
people these these companies will buy
like a decently large Loft and then
stack up like
like five little cute cubes and then
five on top and you crawl into this
little it's probably five feet wide no
four feet wide four feet high and you
crawl into your little mat on the floor
with your TV and your art and that's
your pod everyone shares the kitchen and
bathrooms and there's videos of these
Millennials being like it's just so
awesome it's only eight hundred dollars
per month and it's just like I don't
know for real so much you want to live
you want to live in some of these cities
man
you've looked it's only four a month
with a roommate this this is what you're
gonna get communism you're gonna get
Little Hippie houses buildings where
there's gonna be like 50 Millennials all
living in it and they're sharing their
kids like like their kids are going to
be just communal kids I mean I saw a
tweet and I need to verify this one but
I believe it was from the world economic
forum and it showed young people about
our age living in a tiny house and it
said if you own a big house you're
racist you need to own a small house you
need to own nothing and be happy about
it and I was telling my dad about this
when he came out a little while ago I
said dad I feel a great sense of
almost resentment but very much a sense
of missing something that we never had
because I know now that the American
dream that I grew up with is not
something that I will ever see I will
never see my white picket fence that's
not something that I'm never gonna have
yeah the American dream that's true the
American dream was based on imperialism
and War yeah it wasn't a real thing I
think one of the issues is
I also think Millennials are the first
generation of mass debt college students
I don't think uh Gen X for the most part
was inundated at the same way the
Millennials were the Boomers certainly
weren't so one of the issues is I
believe when I grew up every single
adult was like you have to go to college
and I would just be like why and they
would be alike because otherwise you
won't get a good job and then I'm just
like I don't understand well I told the
story before I read an op-ed from an
economist I think he worked under
Clinton where he said that if you went
to any investor and said you give me
forty thousand dollars in an investment
and in four years you will owe me forty
thousand dollars plus interest and
that's it they would laugh in your face
that's the stupidest investment I've
ever heard of but this is what we're
telling every 18 year old to do to take
out a loan with interest that gets them
no guarantees they don't know why
they're going to college they don't know
where they're going to work when they
get out and a bunch of the a bunch of
these Millennials went in for Liberal
Arts and now they're slammed with debt
confused but but we had the boomer
generation I tell you man they were
screaming screaming my ears they would
shut up about it so now you have an
entire generation saddled with
impossible debt just hating the system
all the problems you mentioned with war
with the financial collapse the security
State and they've just I think they've
just lost the ability to to to function
in any meaningful way relative to the
Past generation I think he hit on a good
point it is something I really worry
about right which is
maybe there are no economic policies
that we're going to have or anything
that are actually going to get things
back to where they were in the 50s and
60s you know maybe all of that was a
just it was a relic of the fact that the
entire world got destroyed and
de-industrialized in World War II except
for us and they all needed American
labor and American Capital and you know
we're five percent of the world's
population we got 30 percent of the
world's resources flowing into the
Imperial Center and maybe that was just
never sustainable and you just wonder
like even if you know we're five percent
of the world's population if we only got
15 instead of 30 percent of the world's
resources we're still like probably at
the top of the Heap I don't think we
could handle I I think there would be a
violent revolution if we had to take a
half a 50 cut in our standard of living
in this country you know and so maybe it
was never it was never something
sustainable I think people just got to
learn to go live in the middle of
nowhere and a lot of people live in the
middle of nowhere are like no you're
gonna ruin the middle of nowhere don't
tell them to come here well but that's
the difficulty right like I remember
when the yellow vest protests were going
on in France
and I read an article by one of the
leaders of it and the thing he said was
this is true in France it's true in the
United States to a large degree is that
the places that you actually have to go
to work are becoming increasingly
concentrated in like a few Urban centers
those places are becoming impossible to
actually live because they're so
expensive because everybody has to go
there
it's like you can I mean there's
probably more you know jobs out in the
middle of nowhere if you're willing to
be an electrician or a plumber or
something like that instead of you know
uh but you know we've spent just God
knows how many hours and and how many
dollars of propaganda to convince people
that that makes them a failure in their
life if they end up doing that so you
know one of the one of the biggest
challenges is we're trying to build this
new studio is you know we're trying to
find a local expert in folklore
mythology but we just can't find any you
know if only there was someone who can
come and read us the the ancient words
that could help us
If Only They can do like a feminist
analysis of the Epic of Gilgamesh you'll
find that that would actually be a good
bit we should do where it's like you
know in order to get the uh the new
studio built way to bring in a feminist
interpretive dancer like you see that
Parliament thing like European
Parliament where they're just dancing
and it's like
oh I think regarding what you said about
standard of living that was interesting
that this would be the first generation
to have a standard of living less than
the generation before and I wonder maybe
financially I agree with you financially
for sure that's what it looks like but
my parents generation got drafted into
Vietnam destroyed their standard of
living I mean annihilated the entire
generation he it ruined their lives and
World War One annihilated the entire
generation give them a little more time
with Russia we'll see what happens yeah
so that's why I'm so anti-war if you
think that even even considering a war
right now is any benefit you got to
understand what countries do with large
on uh uneducated and un uh what do you
call it they don't have a job on
unemployed masses that what they
countries do with those people they send
them to war to die so they don't have to
feed them and take care of them so you
do not want to push for a war
yes yeah yeah but again I think I think
you made a very interesting point about
America's sort of stepping in after the
second world war and becoming this
economic Powerhouse and I hadn't
considered that before
and I want to give it some thought but
another point I like to make when it
comes to the change in the standard of
living is the fact that
the workforce really became
oversaturated because we doubled the
labor Supply once we decided that rather
than a sole bread winner rather than the
father representing the family unit
economically in in working we were going
to have both parents work because that
was somehow you know woman's Liberation
we ended up in a position where your
average worker now had half the
negotiating power and so I think that's
been seriously detrimental to this
country but ultimately whether you're
talking about you know a crony
capitalist system or a capitalist system
which is not managed virtuously or a
communist system
in the end you have a really horrific
situation where your average person does
not have property and therefore no
investment in the system yeah this whole
BlackRock owning property thing's got to
go let's just uh let's just uh start
from step one and this isn't a value
statement or a moral statement
women largely under the workforce around
starting in the 70s and late 70s right
that's when we you know so so I mean for
our our parents generation it was like
they were young adults like all of a
sudden women were getting jobs you know
for me I grew up it was always the case
but once women are in the workforce you
now have
both men and women focused on the
breadwinning aspect of life and no
familial aspect of life so who's gonna
raise the kids well daycare becomes a
question
they now say we need you know businesses
to offer daycare for our kids or public
schooling the government has to replace
the family yep and that is not going to
work out well for anybody it's this slow
creep where
like uh Ted Kaczynski the Unabomber
right talked about this with technology
how a car is invented and it's like wow
now I can get a car and I can drive
wherever I want like I could only walk
or ride my bike before now I can drive I
have the freedom of the road let a
little bit of time go go by and now
having a car is not an option you have
to have a car to survive in our society
at all and you're commuting 45 minutes
to work every day stuck in traffic and
you have no choice it's kind of similar
here like oh wow women can go out and
get a career they can go out and get
jobs now well give it a couple years and
now women have to get jobs both parents
have to work just to survive because
wages have stagnated and costs have gone
up it has a way of working I never hear
the left talk about that they always
show these graphs where it's like I
wonder what happened in 1979 and then I
see this meme where it's like labor
union started losing power and I'm like
it's true but you double the workforce
and your bargaining power gets cut in
half overnight and not just that but
you've got you've got somebody who's you
know running a business and they say to
the guy so tell me about your family
it's like oh my wife works here and you
know we're planning this and this and I
need x amount of dollars like your
wife's got a job you don't need that
much money
like you're you the collective salary
between you and your wife is going to be
75k you're fine yeah I think the
expectation is that you're going to be a
dual income household and so you don't
need to be paid a wage that would be
sufficient for supporting a family and
just to clarify something I said earlier
I said that people who who don't have
property don't have a stake in the
system I misspoke they don't have as
much of a stake there's still a stake in
the system but they are much easier to
control what does the phrase dink is
that it's dual income no kids yeah yeah
I think I think you're right I mean I
think there's some invest like because I
don't want I think property is very
important but also I don't want to say
like if somebody has no property then
like they're not doing things that could
be selfless or beneficial it's not just
property though it's stability yeah
right like you know I've seen uh every
time I go into an airport I see like a
fast company magazine one of those like
new hip Business magazines and it always
have like some kind of cover article
they do and it's one of those recurring
articles that they do again and again in
different you know slightly different
ways and it says like how
for this generation you know the Young
Generation the young people coming up
today are going to change careers six
times throughout their lives and that
the skill or the future isn't going to
be like mastering some skill it's going
to be mastering the art of learning so
that you can go through these changes
like smoothly and it's like well okay
like if you're some super high IQ person
with like a good start you know in your
early 20s and you kind of like knew what
you were doing and you got off on a good
start good for you
but what happens when you know if you
change change careers six times
throughout your life that's six times
maybe you have to move six times that
your friends get changed eventually that
just become I mean I went to like 35
different schools between kindergarten
and 12th grade and by third grade I just
learned like don't make friends it's a
pointless exercise right and so people
learn uh you know don't get too attached
to the place you live don't get too
sentimental about the people you meet
there and so I think there is a loss of
investment you know and then what what
they end up doing is as maybe as a
replacement a prosthetic for that is
they displace that sort of social
concern that they have onto some you
know broad social issues on the federal
level or something like that I think
that can absolutely happen I think that
can absolutely happen and you made a
point earlier about how we couldn't come
in and just cut everyone's standard of
living in half and I was I was
mentioning communism and of course I
believe that you know communism is an
unbelievably horrific barbaric system uh
I mean it's not just a matter of people
not having property they I mean they
slaughter people but at the same time if
a Communist Regime were to be instilled
in the United States and they were to
tell people you know you have to live in
a pod now it would be much more of a
struggle than to just erode the economic
independence of the American people over
time to the point where they say a pod
that's a really great deal or van life
um
yeah I remember when uh that there was
this woman on YouTube who was po she
posted like two van life videos and
gained like three million Subs overnight
because there was apparently some glitch
in the algorithm where she hit all these
key points and so YouTube's algorithm
just showed her videos to literally
everyone so she makes like two videos
with three million Subs
but I it made me made me think of a
potential conspiracy that YouTube was
intentionally promoting van Life as a
way of making Millennials happy being
happy with owning nothing for real think
about what happened so when this van
life Trend was going around like 2018
all these people are on YouTube and
they're like I live in a van I can go
wherever I want I got no rent I got a
computer and my dog and we're going
surfing and then they post these videos
where they're playing that song by I
think it's by Avicii he said one day
you'll leave you or whatever the song
It's Like on repeat and they're all like
running and like filming themselves life
is so good living in a fan down by the
river
and I just I was like I wonder if
YouTube's promoting that because they
want people to own nothing and be happy
and then all of a sudden we got that
video from the world economic Forum that
said you will own nothing and you'll be
happy I will not live in the Pod I will
not eat the boat it's tough to tell
because it's like calling you what does
YouTube want its monolithic corporations
don't have wants but certain people
within the corporations may very well
have that in mind I would think that
most people involved hadn't thought
about that or thought that far ahead it
almost seemed like the dream the
American dream is so prevalent that
people have bought it at that point yeah
well no I think regardless even if it's
not the case that there's an algorithmic
push to direct people towards this kind
of content
Our Generation I would say Generations
prior have really been slowly sold this
idea that Independence is the most
important thing you can possibly have
right so commitment and productivity are
significantly less important than being
able to do whatever you want whenever
you want and it's true that if you are
just living out of a comfortable van
you're not tied down anywhere you don't
have as high of expenses it's much
easier for you to travel I'm not saying
it's a preferable way to live but it is
the way to live that we have been sold
maintaining over time it's not easy they
can't drive I mean you're maintaining a
house is really difficult well yeah I
would say maintaining a Vans probably a
lot less expensive
um but if you're if you're living in a
van I don't know if you're gonna have
the kind of job that's going to be you
know yeah unless you're one of those
family YouTubers look at my whole point
is there's a lifestyle whether it's
there's a lifestyle that's been sold to
us
which is that Independence is the most
important thing it is far more important
as I said than productivity or
commitment building something in the
long term what matters is you can pick
up and leave and do whatever you want
whenever you want and so it's
unsurprising that it's such a huge Trend
all right let's go to super chats if you
have not already give that like button a
decent smashing and head over to
timcast.com where we're going to have a
members only show coming up at 11 PM
tonight you're not going to want to miss
it'll be fun and uh don't forget to
share the show if you really do like it
let's read what all of these super chats
are about something about people
starting Farms with a bunch of farm
animals they want to they want to buy a
bunch of mules or something I don't know
what that is 2 000 I think 2 000 2 000
mules yeah something about that anyway
Amanda dilts is that what it says dilson
please please wish my daughter Riley a
happy birthday she turned four yesterday
and was so excited to get her step on
snack dress like her three other
siblings oh that's awesome we have uh we
made onesies right I think step on snack
and find out once he is it Riley
indoctrinate your kids with Liberty yeah
Riley it's for Riley's birthday Riley
happy birthday birthday Riley happy
birthday Riley oh that's awesome
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says blue
haired fuba wants to do a sex strike
okay oh yeah all right
all right Joe Burns says hey Tim have
you considered making making Sesame
Street like kids TV show starring Ian
and puppet versions of chicken City
chickens with a hidden ongoing joke that
is high on DMT the whole time that's a
good idea
yeah it's got to be called chicken City
with you know oh yeah that's a good idea
chicken City kids and then it's you and
there's puppet chickens and they're like
hey Ian two plus two equals four and
then you're like whoa and then like the
intro to the show is always a DMT trip
but kids don't get it so it's just like
you like the chickens are walking around
like normal chickens but then all of a
sudden they start talking to you oh
that's a good idea you watch it when you
grow up and then you really it's like
watching old Looney Tunes and you
realize how racist they are yeah right
all right so I think it's funny that
people are like the lead story is 2 000
mules whoa why don't you talk about it I
think full disclosure I didn't see it
yeah I've I haven't seen it you know it
was Mother's Day you guys see it it's
preoccupied this is the next one I know
a little bit about it
I know a little bit about it we'll talk
a little bit about it
um Colt says have you watched 2 000
mules if so what were your thoughts I
have not yet seen it but I do know a
little bit about it from reading the
news I know that the mainstream media is
basically basically saying it's all fake
news and one of the criticisms that
Dinesh de Souza brought up is they're
saying there was GPS Data Tracking
people who are dropping off multiple
ballots this is the allegation and the
mainstream media is like GPS data is not
precise enough except there are many
stories from the mainstream media about
how GPS data is actually quite precise
so it's like it definitely seems like
there's a double standard it's been used
in murder trials GPS data yeah and that
uh that serial show you remember the
first season of Serial they talked about
a big part of it was like the GPS data
from his phone like was he in this
location
all right let's see
will S as first Super Chat after more
than a year of listening Friday with
Daryl was an incredible disappointment
but I don't want to give up please
invite him back on for more of what he
did with the clan and maybe a debate
with Seoul I was thinking about the
conversation we have Daryl Davis and I
think what a lot of people uh realized
For the First Time The Story of Daryl
Davis is about a black uh Blues musician
who befriended members of the clan and
other White's premises and convinced
them inadvertently as it was he was the
the impetus by which they gave up being
white supremacists I think for many
people who are anti-identitarian they
heard the story and assumed that he
convinced them not to be racists
but upon hearing the identitarian
opinions of Daryl Davis I think a lot of
people all of a sudden felt like hey how
can this be I thought he was convincing
you know identarians not to want race
policy but he was very much heavily
advocating for race policy I think the
issue is Daryl Davis didn't
de-radicalize members of the clan away
from racism he de-radicalized them away
from white identitarianism meaning they
were it was easy for them to replace the
racism they already had with another
form of it because it was very similar
they were like oh okay racial
discrimination in this way makes sense
right
that's possible yeah I thought a couple
things with Daryl is like different
first if Daryl the story of Daryl Davis
is Bridging the Gap it's not about
believing the same thing as the other
person it's about bridging a gap and so
there's a generation gap and there's
also the race Gap and we that's a
conversation that's not going to be had
in two hours and yeah we should
definitely do it again so I yeah I
wondered because
um we've had we've had conversations and
we've seen interviews with Daryl before
where these issues haven't come up the
way they did on this show yeah so some
people were saying that he had been
radicalized and perhaps the the rise of
critical race Theory and the things he
was quoting are relatively new
phenomenon in modern political context
and you could argue that they're created
in order to radicalize or at least
proliferated in order to radicalize yeah
and and it was it was it was interesting
he was wrong he kept saying that the US
never apologized for slavery but you
brought up in 2008 NPR reported that
Congress did Apologize first yeah there
was an official apology for it I lived
my life several actually my life is an
apology let me make the world better for
you and your friends all right we made a
lot of money tonight from people saying
please see 2 000 mules the movie
so the general idea is that there were
in five key States several people who
they tracked GPS data on that showed
them going to dropboxes multiple times
but several I've seen so again I don't
want to I don't want to criticize too
much because I haven't seen it yet but I
I will check it out uh interesting
questions being raised and and and I
think that's fair uh I think that's it a
lot of people are like you can't bring
it up you'll get banned I'm not I don't
think 2000 mules
um I I my understanding from what I've
already seen in the news and in media
commentary is that it raises certain
questions and requests an answer and
then asks people to look into the
footage and the evidence because there's
a large amount of videos that need to be
gone through I don't I I that's about it
that's where we're at I think it raises
a lot of interesting questions so far
but again need to watch it you need to
watch it for sure I saw some people
already comment that only I think one
video was actually released of a person
doing a multiple ballot drop so I I
don't know I don't know about a whole
lot of I don't know enough I don't know
enough
all right
let's see Rob S has 2 000 Ian's looking
in your soul
all from a different angle Tim Jake says
the NPR story was written by the same
person that claimed conflict between
Gorsuch and Sotomayor over masks a story
proven false she has history of making
claims without supporting facts or
evidence
yep that's right
okay
Kylie Miller says Democrats are going to
lead us to another civil war because
they can't Define what a person is again
exactly yeah that's that's how it goes
right
if you wanted to John Josh one dude says
Tim you blew me away with your arguments
toward the guest Friday I was baffled I
didn't know you had such a big brain
even if you haven't seen him without the
beanie I'm sorry
that's right I like the the there's
someone made a paintbrush meme of my
head is a hot air balloon and I'm
holding the basket and it's like I don't
know how it works that's a good one but
I was like I saved it the funny thing is
like uh you know Ben Shapiro he always
like they make fun of him but he like
laughs at the memes and stuff I I wonder
if these people genuinely think that
they're angering people on the right
with a lot of this stuff
because I just I just think it's funny
it's amazing yeah you also do have a big
brain I don't know I see it more without
the being when you're beating oh yeah
yeah it's just like no but I think I
think it's funny that like it's like you
took the time to draw a picture of me in
paintbrush good for you and it's funny
looking I'm not mad I don't know what am
I what am I going to be mad highly
recommend you guys check out that hot
air balloon meme it's it's really funny
it's pretty good
all right MD Crush says 2 000 mules the
movie is it even banned from you Tim
it's not banned for me I just didn't see
it because it was Mother's Day weekend
and
I don't know it's like busy weekend I
didn't know what it was till today yeah
I heard that people could tell me about
it I was I was I watched I was watching
Clips so I've seen some clips so far
it's a rumble experience some sort of
attack I think their official statement
was that there was an attack on their
servers when it went up people wanted to
stop it from being seen or something no
not gonna work
all right MD Crush as you can see 2000
mules the movie on Rumble that's right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Daryl okay
so there's no fighting fire with fire
voting may work but it's months away is
there any Street action that could
actually work protests peaceful
I think that is charging into the
enemy's strength peaceful protests well
you open yourself up to provocateurs
obviously things like that
um yeah it's just it's dangerous anytime
anybody on the right no matter how
moderate congregates in public you're
you're definitely playing with fire for
sure yeah what is the goal that they're
asking to accomplish
winning the culture war in politics
that's not specific enough tell me the
goal and I think the answer will become
evident yeah I guess it depends on the
context right like if you think about
the parents at those school board
meetings that that was pretty effective
obviously they tried to come down on
them but it's it's having an effect and
things have maybe moved a little bit in
their Direction I think that the right
you know it has to be very smart and it
sort of use a kind of political Jiu
Jitsu anytime they do anything you know
they have to try to take advantage of
single points of failure and the enemy's
defenses do things that produce
predictable overreactions so that those
are the kinds of things you have to do
because that's a good thing about having
a very emotional enemy you know a very
emotional opponent is you can kind of
predict what they're going to do for the
most part and uh you know think about
for example I remember remember when the
Democratic primaries were going on in
2020.
and CNN did an LGBT Town Hall
cool fine and uh yet all the Democratic
candidates there and they kept trotting
out these like six-year-old
seven-year-old kids be like a
seven-year-old boy done up in full
makeup and a dress and he's a little
trans child right and now all the
Democrats who were there they have
pollsters they have you know political
advisors who can tell them that 90 of
the United States thinks that a
six-year-old trans child is that that's
crazy right that that's not a winning
issue every single one of them had to
bend the knee and say I'm so proud of
you this is so amazing you're doing so
great even though they know that there
are political consequences to that
because they have no choice and there
are a lot of issues like that that if
you can draw them out into public all
you have to do is shine a light on them
and they'll they'll melt right before
your eyes
all right Seth Hauser says the baby's
body is not the woman's body I am a
conservative
can you confirm these details Sheamus uh
yeah I would confirm what that he's a
conservative uh well I don't you know I
don't know this individual personally
however the baby's body is not the
woman's body
really bad video says did Ian seriously
argue that a woman's eggs are alive it
cannot understand what a fetus is were
not we all born did not we all require
to be a fetus to be who we are today how
was this ever even an argument killing
babies is not Progressive
um I do understand what a fetus is and
that I do believe the egg is still a
piece of living tissue oh yeah Ian name
three fetuses
you got me Tim useless
all right
uh where are we at
D.E Poland says Tim please have on Abby
Johnson ex-planned Parenthood director
Sheamus should know about her she's a
lot of fun and can really so uh speak to
abortion
can you confirm yeah I'm I'm not overly
familiar with the work I do know of her
yeah she's she's an ex-planned
Parenthood director who became pro-life
oh yeah she's great Brett tesdall says I
am increasingly convinced that abortion
is the Kobayashi Maru of political
debates what is that it was an
impossible test in Star Trek
it was meant to gauge your your um like
how you would behave under absolute
stress right if it drives us to anger
and then conflict we've lost the point
Nick says Ian he says Ethan do you
recall the TNG episode where laforge was
stranded with a Romulan who thought he
should have been aborted because he was
blind
uh I don't if that's where they're in
the cave no I don't think I I saw them
all but I don't off the top of my head
yeah and they were like slowly dying
and they were like starving to death or
something no like something was slowly
killing him was it or whatever I don't
know I always liked those when they put
two cultures like opposing cultures
together in a room and they're forced to
deal with it
atheronzales says consider the rights of
future people there is the booby trap
Time Capsule argument do you have the
right to rig a time capsule to kill
whoever opens it 100 years from now they
aren't born yet if you open the Time
Capsule Now sucks to be you
uh no I think that's illegal to make a
booby trap of any kind like that
but they're not alive right now
like it specifically targets a a unique
person's genetics 100 years in the
future that you don't know if they'll be
well like they bury a time capsule and
then when you dig it out and open it
opens it for yeah something crazy and
you build something that will become a
booby trap in 100 years
I don't know like like uh you have some
piece of I don't know Iron that rusts
and erodes and then
maybe a wild breaks open
like I hate I don't know what the people
of the future are about but I hate them
well when the progressives keep saying
that the future's gonna be Progressive
you know you might get some crazy person
who would think something like I'm gonna
stop these crazy people but I guess the
philosophical argument is if you can
pill if can you kill someone who's not
alive today no no you cannot well like
then then why not a fetus
have you guys seen well they are alive
have you guys seen that South Park
episode where all the people in the
future there's no more jobs in the
future so they're all immigrating back
to the past yeah yeah and they decide
well we have to stop this like you know
just flood of immigration from the
future and so all the men turn gay oh my
gosh and then and then it starts working
but then they no no then they realize if
they make the future a better place
it'll stop the immigration
but then they're like wait a minute why
are we doing this let's go back to the
orgy pile I should clarify you can kill
someone that's not born today although
you might end up in prison for it and
it's not technically viable to murder
someone period this is kind of a crazy
I've never heard this question I know
I've never heard that before
you you'll be alive in 100 years I don't
know about you I think it's certain I
think it's certainly wrong but it's it's
an interesting question I like I think
it would be certainly be wrong to do it
but it is an interesting question I've
never heard anybody ask that before it's
a good one yeah because like people that
time travel like would you go back into
the past to kill Hitler to try to
prevent World War II and I got that
question a lot imagine imagine if like
right now someone came from the future
just like appeared in this room and was
like I have to stop Sheamus and what we
would do everything to protect Sheamus
exactly and I hear liberal and then like
when we when we catch this guy he shows
us like a digital news file and it's
like Sheamus is just like Ultra Hitler
or whatever no it wouldn't even be that
dude if like the progressives win it's
gonna be the one most benign thing ever
be like he one time it'll be like
because I say the word hello and they're
like that's a slur now we've decided you
can't say that or just some insane
cultural shift no it would be benign but
it would be like he he he's a 50 year
old guy who leads this the Free Speech
movement you're gonna have to stop it'd
be something I'm doing now that's
offensive that I'm not sure you gotta
watch out because Looper I don't know if
you guys saw Looper I don't want to
spoil but I'm gonna spoil Looper uh so
turn it down if you haven't seen it yet
um it's the just the act of trying to
kill the kid that turns him into the
villain so don't try and kill Hitler but
that movie made no sense anyway gizmos
89 says Tim you always forget Generation
X no I don't I don't forget Generation X
Generations basically very much skip
like Millennials were the children of
Boomers for the most part there's a
gradient overlap but Gen X like Boomers
were like teenagers or like in their
late 20s when uh well I guess the
problem is the generations can be long
enough to overlap but many Millennials
are the children of Boomers that's the
point how do you do you think about
Generations like I know a lot of people
go by years which I always thought
I always think that's kind of a crude
way of looking at it like when I think
about Generations I think about major
changes in society and where you were at
in your stage of life when they happened
right so like when I think of a
millennial as opposed to a Gen X or like
I'm 40. I was born in 81. I kind of
consider myself like a a really young
gen xer for the most part because I
remember what the world was like without
the internet and the people who like you
know don't really remember that didn't
live any portion of their adult life I
kind of consider millennials but yeah I
always thought of myself as Gen X I was
born in seven but Millennials were grew
up without the internet well they grew
up without it but they didn't live any
of their adult lives without it right so
for Millennials we had rudimentary
internet as kids
but it was like 2007 is is the is the um
is the singularity moment when the
internet became ubiquitous yeah iPhones
and stuff exactly have you seen that
graph that uh
um chewing gum like Revenue purchases
from chewing gum in 2007 just went
cratered and the theory that they have
behind it is that everybody's playing on
their phones in the supermarket Line
This is as good of a theory as I can
come up with
all right Justin Barber says Daryl Davis
mentioned Gore Island I visited there in
2019 and is a special it is it is a
special place is it pronounced Gorey
Gorey Island 360 on YouTube to see an
immersive 360 video I shot on the island
cool oh neat Korea yeah
okay
Phantom
Kitsune zero says when I traveled SE uh
I traveled C I made an effort to try
non-chain places in Foods I could never
find Stateside I envy southeast Asia
there you go I envy Korea and Japan for
having so many options Korea is fun it
was funny when I was in Korea they were
like Chicago pizza with you know like
black sauce on it and I was like we
don't have that that's I don't know what
that is and it was like squid ink or
something on the pizza or something oh
yeah that's that's a thing
I've actually had I've had I've had
squid Pizza calamari on pizza
that sounds delicious yeah it sounds
good yeah I had Giordano's earlier
judge Giordano's earlier didn't invite
me why would I do because I'm the
coolest guy in town
risto says adulthood has been made to
seem undesirable whereas by prolonging
childhood and Adolescence with the
college experience we've warped the
former progression where it was exciting
to enter adulthood
it was a crazy moment for me when I
turned 21. I used to play shows right
and so I would look for Open Mic nights
I would look for venues that allowed all
ages and the clientele of these places
was relatively small because you're
dealing with basically 16 to 21 year
olds because younger than that they're
not really going off by themselves to
these places because they can't drive
so I go to these venues and I play and
then when I turn 21 I was like oh I can
go to this this other venue and then all
of a sudden
everyone there was like in their 20s 30s
40s 50s 60s 70s and I'm just like there
are so many more different kinds of
people now that it was kind of a crazy
moment where I was like wow it was like
like tutorial mode before this now it's
just so many different kinds of people
that I everyone was like me same age
into the same things listening to the
same music then you go to a bar and
everyone's like all different
generations and it's like whoa that was
crazy
yeah I didn't have that that's awesome
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Blitz girl says can Sheamus and
Tim please do your Chicago asking for
Chicago it's so hilariously very funny
so this is Tim and I both had to go to
speech therapy to not talk like this and
the entire reason so we actually
reverted our natural way of speaking
there so when you go to Chicago if you
uh it says it's a secret if you order
your pizza with Chicago exit in here hey
let me get the pepperoni with the uh
extra cheese yeah then they give you
free cheese sticks Victoria's the cheese
sticks there but yeah thank you they go
like so you'll walk into a restaurant
they'll big I'd be like welcome to
Domino's Pizza on your back hey I'm just
like you no no need to put on the accent
I'm like I think fight the Lord I can
finally talk like a normal person I'm
over here somewhere he pulls the old
style can on the wall on a trap door
opens and old style he throws you one
time to relax but it's delish thank you
there hey uh while we're here you need
your garage door repair I do garage door
repairs like yeah so do I though you
guys wanna you guys want to go to really
feel for we can watch the Cubbies loose
the Cubs the Bears Chicago
no one in Chicago even with a Chicago
accent says Chicago no it's never it's
not a thing it's the weirdest thing
that's the one thing people think they
do say they don't say that they don't
say it's funny because
most of the people I know like my dad
for example he almost he like under like
he he does the opposite of a Chicago
accent when he says Chicago you hear
this from a lot of older guys from the
city they'll go like Chicago it's
Chicago yeah they'll they they do not
pronounce it like Chicago no it's the
yeah yeah like Chicago a is the a sound
yeah yeah
it's it's you to do to Chicago to do the
Chicago a you got to go e uh yeah yeah
so Apple it's like it starts with an e
sound defense but it also it depends on
like it's it's also stronger and softer
in different areas too it's changed like
the north side's a little different from
the south side I didn't know I had a
Chicago accent when I lived in Chicago
because everyone around you talks the
same and then it's not until you leave
people like I'll be talking to someone
and they'll go yeppel and then I'll be
like what they'll say you said apple and
I'll be like yeah I said apple and then
go no you said yeah I said yeah what's
wrong with saying the Apple what are you
talking about man I said yeah
genius bear
all right
NY bsfp says agree with Tim on St
regardless of what they may have
intended on St
age
oh and Star Trek what they showed was
people fighting for freedom from a
government that eventually nuked them
who has the nukes
China no David C Croc says Tim you are
talking about the franchise that made
Stacey Abrams the president of United
Earth
and talk about running a show you know
what the Picard is about
Q have you ever seen Star Trek not
really I've seen a couple episodes
this I know who Q is he he he transports
them to the characters to an alternate
timeline where the Galaxy is run by an
earth Empire of human supremacists and
then Picard's like we have to go back to
the year 20 to the 21st century to stop
something from happening that made
humans racial supremacists and like I
stopped watching it I was just like off
and then and then Q was like back in
this time I had a messaging board where
I used to post things about politics to
mess with people
don't you understand that the people at
that time were racists okay Bill
Q I went to a antique store and found an
unopened Q action figure from like 1992.
needless to say I bought it
I'm very excited for that purchase is
that why they call that although message
boards Q is from the Star Trek guy I
have no idea what I don't know yeah I
don't know what are you talking about no
because I was joking because Q yeah
it means like uh it's a classification
level I think or something like that
yeah
right right
Sam weiter says Tim I've commented on
this before that Star Trek has predicted
the future and I believe that 2024 will
be the deciding year since it's been
shown in DS9 and picardo oh
[Music]
perhaps right Hillary is going to become
president and fix everything
Sr Dempsey says Dragon Distillery and
Frederick might be able to help you with
your design goals
design goes for What dragon Distillery
oh no oh I can confirm Q clearance Q
access authorization U.S department of
energy security clearance required to
access top secret restricted data
I don't know if I believe it
Christopher Shipley says thank you again
Tim for coming by 4D Fun Center over the
weekend also thank you for explaining
how cheap those Tony Hawk boards we had
were did some research after and marked
them as starter boards oh I wouldn't
even necessarily call them that we went
to this place called the 4D Fun Center
they had bowling they had an escape room
we did an escape room that was a great
place
um and uh won a bunch of tickets played
played the arcade games played some uh
they have a beer pong arcade did you do
the escape room yeah did you escape yes
did you escape fast uh I think we had
six minutes left out of a half an hour
you get a half an hour to solve it but
you know what the issue was for us is
that we were too smart we were too smart
for our own good this actually is an
issue so you know my brother's trying to
point out don't overthink the puzzles
these are for like this is a mass Market
thing yeah well it's like a kid's place
like so the puzzles are simple what have
people feel really smart look guys well
the puzzles were all like relatively
simple like find the codes it's like a
clock and it's like there's there's I
want to give I don't want to spoil it
but one of the things is that one of the
objects in the room we thought was a
code was actually all of the codes and
we didn't realize that that would be the
one anomalous thing and so we couldn't
figure it out we were confused by it and
that took us like 10 minutes
yeah there were longer ones there's like
hour ones yeah but but the door was open
the whole time I did one of those one
time and we were looking like on the
bottom side of the radio at the serial
number and trying to figure out if it
meant anything none of it meant anything
it was like you know right over there
yeah the daily wire didn't escape room
challenge where they mixed and matched
people and then they were competing
against other daily wire teams but it
was teams so you got to see them
interact and how they were getting
stressed with each other but having fun
too well I have an idea me and my friend
had an idea a long time ago for
something called the hacker games
and the idea is to get a building
secure it in a variety of ways digital
keypad locks security guards pin and
Tumble locks and then in the top floor
in one of the rooms is the McGuffin and
the goal is to get the MacGuffin without
being like being able to break into this
building we would hire security guards
but not tell them it was a show
so we just we hire a security guard and
say you know don't let anybody in
without the proper credentials
you know but the thing is it's so easy
to get past the security guard you know
the easiest way to get past a security
guard at a venue at least is a good
example is you just carry a bag of ice
you put a rag in your back pocket grab a
bag of ice and you will walk right past
them and they will never ask you a
question hear that security guards eyes
open yep look for those ice guys so then
what happens if like you and all your
friends each have
ice bags in your back pocket if there's
like up there's just a bunch of guys
with ice if there was like two or three
guys and you're carrying trays and Ice
you're gonna be and then you walk up the
security guard and go uh where do we put
the stuff he's gonna be like uh try the
kitchen you're gonna go thanks man
you're gonna walk right past them I was
at a venue once and uh I had a pass but
they weren't allowing me to go backstage
so I walked I just the first thing you
do is you own the place so I just walked
past the security guard and then he went
whoa whoa whoa and then he put his hand
in front of me where you going I was
like I'm working and he was like no no
no no you can't come in here without the
right you know pass and I was like I got
the pass right here it's on my leg and
he was like that pass is not for here
and I'm like dude I'm at work and he was
like sorry bro you can't come in and I
was like
so I went into the I started walking
around I saw a guy with the camera I was
like hey come with me you want to go
backstage and he's like yeah come with
me and then we started walking back
towards the security guard same guy
again and then this time we both walked
past and he goes yo yo I told you can't
come and then I interrupt him go dude
we're working and he sees the camera guy
goes oh oh I'm sorry dude and then we
walk backstage and hung up
but that's that's the idea for the game
so pick the locks or hack the codes and
then try and find your way in I want to
do it we just it requires you know
getting to that point where we can set
it up so maybe in the next couple of
years we'll get something like that
going that'll be a bluff skill in
Dungeons and Dragons that you passed I
gotta tell you getting past security
guards at corporate functions or at
buildings is just like
I don't even understand what the point
of having a security guard is for the
most part like first it's a deterrent
yeah I think most people are most people
are real followers so I I think it's
mostly about like insurance and
um and um having a dedicated person for
security issues so if something comes up
they handle the job but getting past the
security guard anywhere is just like I
don't know man it's easy like you see it
in movies all the time it's like you
wait out by the door smoking a cigarette
they open the door and you go hey man
you just walk in it's like
geez all right let's see we'll grab uh
we'll grab one more
hangover bear says you talk about the
financial crisis of the 2000s if as if
it was the only generation to go through
one talk to the kids that grew up from
the mid 70s and mid 80s yeah I mean what
about Boomers and the gas shortages and
the inflation problem I mean everybody
and Vietnam there was a lot of bad stuff
going on for sure those things were I
think a lot more
recoverable when they were over though
you know like think about all of the
1960s college students who uh and just
young people in general who decided to
just take a few years off go smoke weed
out in the countryside and party it up
and kind of do their maybe go out and
like engage in riots and protests and
just be a revolutionary and then a few
years go by yeah it's time to like get
my act together and they go off and they
finish college and they go get a job at
like a big Law Firm or something right
how many all the weathermen ended up the
ones who didn't get arrested for murder
ended up going and working for big law
firms or going to universities whereas
it feels like today
you know you get a you know people these
people had felonies on their records and
they got done and they went and got jobs
universities it just feels like much
more punitive today if you make mistakes
or waste time you know all right
everybody if you haven't already give
that like button a good smashing
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really do like it that Grassroots
marketing is is marketing is really
really helpful we've got some some fun
stuff coming up in terms of our culture
jamming campaigns you're gonna really
enjoy them head over to timcast.com and
click the sign up button become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
going live at about 11 pm and we'll be
not so family friendly and uh you know
you don't want your kids to watch these
shows but they're a lot of fun a lot of
swearing so uh check that out again
smash that like button you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast basically everywhere Daryl
you want to shout anything out
um check out the podcast martyrmade
m-a-r-t-y-r-m-a-d-e and the unraveling
with me and Jaco willink all right got a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
upload a cartoon every single week
sometimes twice a week I think you guys
are gonna like work but not this week go
over there check it out love you Tim is
swinging for the fences all these bugs
flying around give me give me hey also
your martyr made on Twitter if people
want to follow you on social media just
throw out are you pretty much Marta made
everywhere yes guys I'm Gonna Roll the
100-sided die I talked about Tim's Bluff
check alert I rolled a 68 and I'm gonna
give you a wild magic surge for that
number it's a 68 magic yeah so if I was
a wild Mage which I am I permanently
gain one can trip a spell such as remove
curse can end this effect so yes I'm
cursed but it could be beneficial we'll
find out all right I like this new
tradition I just wanted to add before we
left that we were talking about the
Reddit Thread about ladies getting off
these dating apps and I want to give
credit to Aaron McIntyre who says
periodically progresses her reverse
engineer healthy sexual behavior and
then act like they've discovered
Atlantis I think that's what we're
seeing here they do this all the time
with families and they're like being all
rebellious and everything and we're like
yes this is exactly what we've been
saying this whole time anyway from our
hot takes like that you guys can follow
me on twitterminds.com at Sarah
patchlitz and check me out on
sarahpatchlits.me we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys